Wir wollen sprechen über den europäischen Top-Fußball bei den Männern. Wir sprechen heute über Spanien, England, Italien und über die Ähre de Vigée, also die Niederlande. Jetzt hier mit Daniel Zander, Christian Bernhard, Nies Kern und Uli Hebel kommt auch noch mit dazu. Was für ein Setup. Los geht's. Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Hallo und herzlich Willkommen liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ein Tag später als geplant. Also ich hoffe zumindest, dass ich das hier einen Tag später als geplant veröffentlicht habe. Wir wissen es alle noch nicht. Es muss ein bisschen improvisiert werden aktuell beim Rasenfunk. Ich entschuldige mich dafür und wir machen es wett, indem wir jetzt lieber gleich in ein Thema reinstarten, bevor wir hier die Aufnahme wieder unterbrechen müssen. Nils, wenn du magst, dann leg du doch mal los. Was hast du uns aus Spanien mitgebracht? Und schön, dass du hier bist.
Ja, danke, finde ich auch. Ich finde es auch immer schön, dass mittlerweile zwei Real Madrid-Legenden im Intro zu hören sind. Kilian, ja, ich habe einen besonderen Club mitgebracht, bei dem steht Form Stadion Unique in the World dran. Bei dem merkt man auch, dass das einiges einzigartig ist, auch wie sie in der Liga spielen. Das ist mit Blick auf die Tabelle der mittlerweile souveräne Tabellenvierter der Athletik Club. Kennen ja viele die Geschichte, es werden nur Nachwuchsspieler aus der Gegend im Bastenland eingesetzt und so weiter. Das haben sie schon immer. Sie sind Liga-Kündigungsmitglied, Liga, Dino, so gesehen. Schreiten da schon eine einzigartige Geschichte. Aber mittlerweile ist das auch sportlich auf einem sehr hohen Niveau. Und sie sind da absolut auf Champions-League-Kurs. Hat jetzt die letzten, inklusive Europa League, sechs Spiele gewonnen, sind seit zwölf Spielen ungeschlagen. Das sind schon mal okaye Zahlen und trotzdem für einen eigentlich Club, der jetzt nicht unbedingt die ganz großen Rasenfunk-Introspieler mit dabei hat. Von Real wurde letztens auch geschlagen, 2-1 auch ordentlich verdient geworden eigentlich. Ist das bemerkenswert, sie spielen ein herausragendes Pressing in der Liga, womit auch er Madrid Probleme hatte. Vielleicht auch bei der FC Barcelona, da kommt es in der Supercopa am 8. Januar zum Halbfinalduell. Ja und man merkt einfach, dass da einfach weiter was zusammenwächst. Ernesto Valverde, Ex-Basa-Trainer, ist jetzt zum dritten Mal beim Athletic Club als Trainer dabei, 2022 gekommen. Danach hatten sie jetzt in diesem Jahr die Copa del Rey gewonnen, das erste Mal nach 40 Jahren. Also da merkt man, da wächst weiter was zusammen. Sie haben endlich auch ein bisschen das Thema Aritz Aduriz, war ja lange der große Mittelstürmer, legendär. Da haben sie jetzt seit ein, zwei Jahren Gokka, Gudos Deter, der funktioniert auch und mittlerweile einfach auch kann man sagen, dass Athletik nicht mehr nur ausbildet und gute Nachwuchsspiele hat, die auch mal in die Nationalmannschaft schaffen, unter anderem und da ist Simon, nicht Williams, sondern sie können sie nicht nur ausbilden, sondern auch halten die Talente und da ist es auf jeden Fall erwähnenswert, dass dort die Arbeit immer mehr Früchte trägt. In der Europa League sind sie ja auch ganz oben mit dabei, von dem her ist das unique in the World und unique in la Liga irgendwie.
Aber wirklich, du hast jetzt im Grunde schon fast alles gesagt, so fühlt es sich an, aber wenn ich mir die Tabelle angucke, und die haben ja nicht alle Hörerinnen und Hörer vor Augen, dann haben wir Barca vorne 38 Punkte, Real dahinter mit 36 Punkte, Atletico Madrid mit 35 und dann kommt eben Athletik Bilbao mit 32 und dann gibt es einen Gap. Sechs Punkte sind es dann schon auf Viareal. Ist das eine Momentaufnahme oder würdest du sagen, vielleicht ist es wirklich so, dass das quasi gerade die Top 4 sind, die in einer in Anführungszeichen eigenen Liga spielen?
Kann man an sich schon sagen, jetzt ist bei Viareal speziell durch die Flutkatastrophe um Valencia noch ein Spiel weniger, also ein bisschen die Tabelle verzerrt, aber es gibt schon Teams, wo man sagen kann, die sind sehr launescht, defensiv anfällig, da gehört auch ein Viareal dazu, die immer mal wieder für einen Patzer gut sind. Und die letzten Jahre waren es ja eigentlich immer die Top 3, die da vorne waren, auch mal wie ja letztes Jahr noch Girona. Und da wirkt aktuell Athletik so konstant. Und wie gesagt, schon die letzten Jahre unter Valverde haben sich da so entwickelt, dass man sagen kann, da entsteht was und irgendwie, wenn es mal einen Rückschlag gibt, wird nicht gleich alles über einen Haufen geworfen. Mittlerweile ist es auch nicht nur so, dass sie einen 10, 11, 12 gute Basten haben, sondern auch auf der Bank kann mal ein Berenguer reinkommen. Sie haben sich aus Braga Alvaro Jalo geholt, der auch baskische Wurzeln hatte. Also mittlerweile ist der Kader dann auch breit genug, um dann auch diese berühmte Doppelbelastung auszuhalten. Eure Sunset spielt bisher eine überragende Saison, gehört zu den torgefährlichsten Mittelfeldspielern aller Ligen überhaupt. Und von dem her ist das keine Momentaufnahme, glaube ich. Ich hatte sie auch auf Platz 4 getippt, aber es war auch ein bisschen obvios. Wie gesagt, wir haben ja sehr defensiv anfällig, Realsfossidat auch extrem schwankend und Bettis ist auch irgendwo, vielleicht irgendwo der Zyklus vorbei, aber Athletik einfach lobenswert. Oder auch mal wieder so ein typisches Beispiel für langfristige Arbeit. Christian hat ja schon oft gesagt, Atalanta ja vorgehoben, aber auch in Deutschland sieht man ja Teams wie Heidenheim, Elbersberg, wo auch mal an Trainern festgehalten wird und irgendwie ein langfristiges Team aufgebaut wird. Und da Athletik ist da einfach eine schöne Geschichte mal wieder.
Ja, und dann erfüllen Sie halt auch das alte Klischee von baskischen Vereinen, hätte ich fast schon gesagt, nämlich die Heimstärke. Stärkstes Team gemeinsam mit Real, 21 der Punkte hat man zuhause geholt. Und so hat man ja auch unter anderem gegen Real gewonnen. Also das war wieder so ein klassisches Athletikspiel, oder?
Ja, im Sun Mammes ist es schön anzuschauen. Ich hatte auch einen Redakteur vor, das ist schon beeindruckender, aber es tut auch immer weh als Gegner. Und das ist mittlerweile nicht nur in KO spielend, da ist Real Madrid-Basel da öfter mal ausgeschieden im Sun Mammes, jetzt mittlerweile auch in der Liga. Real hatte davor schon auch mal irgendwie einen neuen Spieler ungeschlagen, Serie gegen Athletic Club, aber jetzt waren es mal dran. Jetzt können sie auch endlich ihre Chancen, sind effektiver geworden. Auch da hat man die letzten Jahre noch gemerkt, Nico Williams vor dem Tor noch eine gewisse Streuung. Auch das ist jetzt zielstrebiger, genauer geworden. Also sie wachsen weiter zusammen und sind da jetzt auf Champions League Kurs absolut.
Weil du gerade Nico Williams erwähnt hast und über den haben wir ja spätestens bei der EM ist er jedem aufgefallen und jeder. Gibt es denn einen Spieler, wo du sagst, der ist jetzt noch nur La Liga ExpertInnen bekannt und der wird aber richtig durchstarten?
Ja, würde ich jetzt nochmal glaube ich auch an Sunset erwähnen, so Spielmacher, zentrales Mittelfeld, auch sehr torgefährlich, auch großer Arbeiter, gute Laufstärke. Der könnte jetzt bestimmt auch mal mit der Nationalmannschaft berufen werden. Niko ist klar, wie gesagt auch gar kein Guldo Seta, mag ich die Mittelstimme, auch wenn der jetzt nicht unbedingt das Weltklasse-Niveau hat, aber passt gut und dieses Team. Aber Euran Sunset da als Zehner ist ein guter Name.
Hat er schon in der Nationalmannschaft gespielt, da bin ich mir grad gar nicht sicher.
Ich mein noch nicht, nee.
Er war jetzt in der Qualifikation mal mit dabei. Das war, ja, genau, stimmt, der war da nominiert, hat er sogar ein Tor gemacht. Richtig. Jetzt erinnere ich mich wieder, aber nur mit Gedächtnisstütze hier. Okay, Euran Sunset, wir merken uns diesen Namen und wir verbieten uns jetzt schon, also ich mir alle Sonnenuntergangs-Wortspiele, die man damit machen könnte, in völliger Unkenntnis der Orthografie seines Namens. Aber das ist was anderes. Die Sonne geht auf, denn Uli Hebel ist jetzt hier mit. Hallo Uli, schön, dass du da bist.
Hallo, grüß dich. Ich hab schon gedacht, wann kommt es denn endlich?
Naja, so muss es ja sein. Also schön, dass du da bist, aber du musst dich noch ein bisschen gedulden. Wir gehen jetzt erst noch die Reihenfolge weiter durch. Ich würde sagen, Daniel, wenn du magst, kannst du uns mal dein Hauptthema aus der Eredivisie mitbringen. Was ist denn da besonders wichtig zu wissen aktuell?
Ja, moin in die Runde. Es ist bei mir ein vereinsübergreifendes Thema heute, ein liegereübergreifendes Thema von der Eredivisie, was auch sehr diskutabel ist, ein Glücksspiel und Wettanbieter. Es gab eine Entwicklung in den letzten Wochen und Monaten, die ich persönlich eigentlich befürworte. Die Kanzspielautorität, das ist quasi eine Behörde staatliche, hat die Werbe stärker reguliert. Das heißt, Online-Wettanbieter und Online-Casinos dürfen ab der kommenden Saison, ab Juli 25 nicht mehr im Sportsponsor wegen Tätis sein, also keine Stadionnamen mehr vermarkten, nicht auf dem Trikot sein, Bandenwerder wird eingeschränkt. Das wird quasi wirklich sehr stark, strikt reguliert. Und genau wie gesagt, ich finde das persönlich nicht schlecht. Den Verein allerdings wird natürlich die Hände ein bisschen schwitzig, weil es ist, wenn man mal schaut, wer alles in der ersten und auch zweiten Liga in der Eredivisie mit diesem Sponsoring arbeitet, merkt man dann schon, es gibt kaum einen Verein, der es nicht tut. Und gerade es ist von Ajax über kleinere Vereine zu Predator komplett durchgesponsort in diesem Bereich leider. Und auch in der zweiten Liga, da sieht man zum Beispiel als den SC Telstar, das ist ein kleinerer Verein aus Nord-Holland, da ist es so, der Stadionname hat einen Online-Casino-Namen, der Hauptsponsor ist ein Online-Casino. Und es gab auch mal, bevor sie den bekommen haben, 23, haben sie quasi so eine Ausschreibung gestartet, wir suchen einen Hauptsponsor. Und da war die Zahl 3000 Euro drinnen zu lesen. Und das ist natürlich für so einen kleinen Verein aus der zweiten Jahrincheniiga ein stolzer Betrag. Und das wird eine sehr spannende Umstrukturierung werden, auf finanzieller Sicht bei vielen Vereinen aus den ersten beiden Ligen. Und gespannt sein darf, was dort als Ausgleichsponsoring passieren wird. Und das war aber eine Situation, die war jetzt schon vor ein paar Wochen, ein paar Monaten geschlossen worden, es ist bekannt, die Sachen laufen aus, dürfen nicht verlängert werden. Und jetzt vor drei Tagen kam aber dann die Nachricht, die für sehr viele Diskussionen gesorgt hat. Denn in der kommenden Saison haben wir ja gesagt, diese Sponsoring wird eingestellt, vom Staat reguliert, aber die Eredivisie bekommt einen neuen Sponsornamen. Und so wie ich es von aboderiere, ist das eine Lotterie, ja natürlich. Und das wird noch viel lustiger, in Anführungszeichen, wenn man dann sagt, Lotterie ist staatlich, die diesen Namen verleiht. Das heißt, wir haben auf der einen Seite den Staat, der Online-Casinos und Online-Metanbieter regulieren möchte stärker und dieses Werbeverbot im Sportbereich einführt. Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir dann die staatliche Lotterie, die den Namensgeber, bis ich glaub, 28, 29, der Liga wird. Und alle Partien werden dann unter diesem Label geführt werden. Und das ist natürlich etwas, was sehr diskutabel ist. Diese Behörde hat es begründet damit, dass die Lotterie ja erstens keine reine Online-Lotterie sei, sowie die Online-Casinos. Und sie haben es damit begründet, dass es ja auch eine, das heißt in den Niederlanden Rude-Duel-Lotterie ist. Die spendet also angeblich 40 Prozent des Umsatzes an gute Zwecke. Das reicht dann als Legitimation für diese Ausnahme. Auf der anderen Seite sage ich trotzdem, es ist trotzdem auch Glücksspiel. Und wenn man sich das Ziel nimmt, 40 Prozent an gute Zwecke zu spenden. Auf der anderen Seite zappt man dann bei Millionen für Sponsoring. Das kann man natürlich auch sehr rütig hinterfragen. Und dazu kommt noch, es gibt Gerüchte, das ist jetzt nicht bestätigt, aber es gibt Gerüchte, dass eben auch andere Angebote auf den Tisch lagen für die Giga, von anderen Branchen, die weit weniger behaftet sind. Und die wurden sich wohl nicht mehr angehört. Also das ist für alle Fußball-Kreisalisten auf mehreren Ebenen eigentlich eine schlechte Nachricht. An sich haben wir jetzt diesen Sponsornamen drinne. Das ist ja nichts Neues, wenn man nach Frankreich guckt, mit der Liga kennt man das ja, die hat ja auch einen Sponsornamen, von der Fast-Foot-Kette glaube ich. Und auf der anderen Seite hat man dazu noch diesen Wettanbieter, was natürlich auch nochmal einen Schlag in die Magen ging, das endlich ist. Und ja, damit müssen wir jetzt aber leben. Das wird nicht mehr zu ändern sein, vermutlich.
Daniel, ich habe Fragen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Ich würde mich jetzt selbst einschränken müssen. Also vorne angefangen, die staatliche Behörde verbietet das. Was war die Begründung?
Die Begründung war, dass die Online-Casinos und Online-Wettanbieter mit Bezugung auf Online ein zu hohes Risiko sind. Ja, und die Argumente, die wir eigentlich auch kennen, wurden angeführt, es ist einfach ein Risikospiel und sie wollen es regulieren, damit weniger Leute in Suchtmuster fallen.
Okay, also Risiko quasi in Suchtgefahr zu leiten.
Genau.
Und dann haben wir ja, das haben wir ja in allen Ländern, das haben wir auch in Deutschland. In Deutschland kann man sich ja auch die Frage stellen, warum gibt es so viele Sportwettanbieter und so weiter und so fort? Und warum werden die nicht noch härter reguliert? Glücksspiel, Staatsvertrag eins bis drei und so weiter und so fort. Das Tribüngespräch dafür bereite ich schon seit ein paar Jahren vor und komme aber nicht dazu. Und auch da hat man das Paradoxon, dass eben auf der einen Seite die die Staaten selbst Lotterien betreiben und auch das ganze Geschäft in den Weißbereich ziehen wollen. Also eben nicht im Graubereich, wo es im illegal versickert mögliche Steuereinnahmen, sondern du wirst die Steuereinnahmen haben und sie betreiben eben zum Teil eigene Lotterien. Und auf der anderen Seite müssen sie aber ihre Bevölkerung schützen vor Sucht. Und wenn man sich da die Zahlen anguckt, muss man sagen, das passiert nicht gut genug und dementsprechend ist dann wahrscheinlich da unter reguliert. Glaubst du denn, dass das jetzt das Ganze ins Wanken bringen könnte? Denn die niederländische Politik und die staatlichen Behörden, die das entschieden haben, die agieren ja in einem europäischen Rahmen. Und da könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, also das Allererste, was ich jetzt als Sportwettanbieter machen würde, da nehme ich jetzt mal wirklich die Rolle des Advokatos Diaboli ein, wäre dagegen zu klagen und zu sagen, das ist ein Diskriminierendes Agieren der niederländischen Behörden und das dann auf EU-Ebene einzufordern. Meinst du, das wird das nächste sein oder weiß man schon, was da jetzt passieren kann? Das könnte doch alles ins Wanken bringen.
Also diese Grundsatzentscheidung, dass die Online-Casinos und Online-Metal-Anbieter stärker reguliert werden und ab 25 nicht mehr in der Liga werden dürfen, das gibt es schon länger, diese Entscheidung wird einige Monate, glaube ich. Und da hat man jetzt zumindest, stand jetzt noch nichts gehört von irgendwelchen Klagen, irgendwelche Decides. Deswegen, das kann natürlich nicht ausgeschlossen sein. Es wäre zumindest der logische Schritt von den Metal-Anbietern, letztendlich. Aber gehört ist da noch nichts. Und das nierhändische Recht ist da auch sehr differenziert. Also ich hab da immer die ganzen, auf der Behördenseite ist es sehr, wie ich finde, übersichtlich strukturiert und aufgebaut. Da gibt es sehr, sehr viele Fallstricke und sehr, sehr viele Details, letztendlich deswegen ich vermute, dass das sowieso schon auch teils in Kooperation mit diesen Glücksspielanbietern passiert ist. Und da auch schon quasi lobbyistisch sehr viel ausgehandelt wurde im Vorfeld. Deswegen vielleicht so auch mögliche Klagen umgangen worden. Aber ich kann es wirklich nicht, ich weiß es nicht ganz genau, aber ich vermute schon, dass das kommen kann, auch wenn ich es nicht glaube.
Okay, das ist natürlich interessant. Dazu fehlt uns jetzt leider die Zeit, aber wir werden das Thema jetzt auf jeden Fall auf dem Schirm haben. Und ich finde es durchaus erstaunlich, ich habe nebenher versucht, da mal mir ein paar Dinge zu kursieren und zu googeln. Keine Treffer unter den Nachrichten. Also ist in Deutschland noch nicht so wirklich gelandet das Thema. Wer weiß, was dafür die Gründe sind. Aber sehr, sehr interessant, es gibt entsprechende Initiativen auch in der Premier League. Die sind noch nicht so weit gekommen, da haben sich die Vereine dagegen entschieden. Und klar, wenn du die Vereine mitreden lässt, die werden sich immer dagegen entscheiden. Auch wenn du die Sender mitreden lässt, die werden sich immer dagegen entscheiden, denn es kommt wahnsinnig viel Geld über Sportwettanbieter in den Fußball. Und alles weitere dazu können sich alle Hörerinnen und Hörer denken. Auch meine Haltung dazu dürfte relativ klar sein, dass es einer der Hauptgründe, warum es keine Werbung im Rasenfunk gibt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Denn ihr könnt euch ja vorstellen, wer da als allererstes käme, um hier zu werben und wo wir dann sagen würden, nein, danke, möchten wir nicht. Und dann kannst du es dir nämlich auch sparen im Fußballbereich. Also danke Daniel für die Entwicklung, sehr, sehr interessant und da bleiben wir auf jeden Fall dran. Und dann ist die Frage, Christian, an was bleiben wir in der Serie A dran in Zukunft?
Also ich habe euch einen Club mitgebracht, der von den vergangenen 17 Spielen, Pflichtspielen 14 gewonnen hat. Und dieser Club ist aber nicht Inter, ist nicht Juve, ist nicht Napoli, ist nicht Atalanta, sondern wir reden mal in Ruhe über Lazio. Weil die sich das mehr als verdient haben in dieser Saison. Wir haben es ja schon immer wieder mal kurz angerissen über einzelne Personen. Aber es ist mal höchste Zeit sich das anzuschauen. Also wirklich herausragend was Lazio macht. Wie gesagt, sie sind in der Spitzengruppe, in der Serie A vorne dran an Inter und Atalanta, in der Europa League auf Platz 1, haben am Donnerstagabend bei Ajax gewonnen. Das hat Daniel verfolgt logischerweise. Haben da bis auf ein Gruppenspiel bisher auch alle gewonnen und haben vergangene Woche Napoli 3 zu 0 aus dem Pokal rausgekegelt. Also bei Lazio läuft's. Und das Spannende daran ist, wenn man im Sommer zurückgeht, dann hat im Sommer Lazio sich von Giro Immobili getrennt. Dem Lazio-Spieler der vergangenen Jahrzehnte. Ganz einfach, Rekordtorschützen, alles drum und dran, glaube ich. Wissen die meisten, was der für Lazio bedeutet hat. Von Luis Alberto getrennt, mit der beste Fußballer, den Lazio in den letzten Jahren hatte. Und wenn wir uns den Sommer davor noch dazunehmen, dann ist auch Milonkovic Savic, also ein Sommer davor gegangen. Also im Prinzip hat sich Lazio jetzt in den letzten zwei Sommern von den drei Spielern getrennt, die im Prinzip diese Mannschaft bestimmt haben die letzten Jahre. Und dementsprechend logisch viele Fragezeichen waren da im Umfeld. So von wegen, oh mein Gott, jetzt gehen wir die ganzen Großen her, wo soll das alles hingehen? Ja, wo es hingehen kann, sieht man jetzt, weil wir diese drei ansprechen. Also mich erinnert das wahnsinnig stark an die Napoli-Zeit von vor zwei Jahren. Vielleicht erinnerst du dich auch noch ein paar. Bevor Napoli diesen großartigen Scudetto gewonnen hat, im Sommer davor haben sie sich von Insigne getrennt, von Mertens getrennt, von Coulibaly getrennt. Und auch Fabian Ruiz ist damals gegangen. Jetzt bei Fabian Ruiz war es logischerweise nicht eine Entscheidung aus Altersgründen oder so. Aber und da war im Sommer in Neapel auch, ja gut, okay, unsere besten Leute gehen, das war's. Ja, heraus kam das Scudetto. Ich will jetzt nicht falsch verstehen, ich will jetzt nicht damit sagen, dass Lazio auch dieses Jahr das Scudetto gewinnt. Aber was man daran, glaube ich, ganz gut sehen kann, ist, dass es manchmal ganz gut tun kann, wenn du einfach die alteingesessenen langjährigen Führungsstrukturen in einem Club und sowohl die Lazio-Namen, die ich aufgezählt habe, als auch die Napolinamen, das waren, selbst erklärend, wahnsinnig dominante Spieler im Club. Und da geht es jetzt gar nicht darum zu sagen, dass die da schlechte Stimmung verbreitet haben, sondern es geht einfach nur darum, ich glaube manchmal ist es ganz gut, wenn du einfach eine komplett neue sportliche, ich meine aus Spielersicht Führungsebene reinkommt. Also einfach wenn komplett frischer Wind reinkommt, weil das nämlich dazu führt und das hat man bei Napoli gesehen und das sieht man bei Lazio jetzt auch, weil dann Spieler manchmal aus dem Schatten dieser großen Namen treten und dann selbst wahnsinnig in die Verantwortung reingehen. Und auch das ist bei Lazio der Fall. Zaccani haben wir schon angesprochen mal bei den Tops. Spielt eine überragende Saison, ist der neue Kapitän, füllt diese Rolle perfekt aus. Gendozzi, französischer Nationalspieler, überragende Saison. Rovella, zentraler Mittelfeldspieler, italienischer Riesenschritt gemacht. Also das sind Spieler, die jetzt einfach in diese Führungshalle reinwachsen mussten und die aber halt auch einnehmen, weil sie halt diese anderen großen Namen nicht mehr vielleicht so ein bisschen neben sich spüren. Das so zur allgemeinen Einleitung, wo wir jetzt unbedingt dazukommen müssen, ist der Trainer Marco Baroni. Er wurde ja auch schon angerissen und das ist wirklich eine Geschichte. Ich glaube, die kann man nicht, also die muss man kurz, ja ein bisschen tiefergehend erzählen, denn bei Baroni war im Sommer auch ungefähr bei allen Beobachtern, okay Lazio holt Baroni, was soll das, gibt Immobilie ab, geblößt sein Wert ab, ja wollen die jetzt achter, neunter, zehnter werden. Und das ist halt die klassische Geschichte eines Trainers, der in den vergangenen Jahren wirklich immer das Bestmögliche herausgeholt, was er rausholen konnte, aber das Ganze halt eher bei kleineren Vereinen und dann vielleicht nicht so diesen Sexiness-Faktor hatte. Aber wenn man sich die letzten Jahre anschaut, der hat vor zwei Jahren, ist er mit Lecce aus der Serie B aufgestiegen als Meister, also mehr kannst du nicht machen, dann hat er im Jahr darauf Lecce mit dem Kleinstnet da, also Lecce hat angeblich sogar einen der kleinsten Etats in der Top-5-Ligen, also wirklich nicht nur in Italien, sondern komplett liegengübergreifend, hat er in der Liga gehalten und vergangenen Saison würde ich sagen, hat er sein Meisterstück gemacht, denn da hat er Hellas, Verone in der Liga gehalten. Das an sich ist jetzt noch nicht alleine ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal, aber das Besondere war Hellas wurden, also ihm wurden im vergangenen Januar sechs Stammspieler verkauft. Also stellt euch vor, du bist ein Abstiegskandidat, musst eh schauen, dass du da irgendwie am Leben bleibst, und dann verkauft dir deine Vereinsführung um Januar sechs Stammspieler und er hat im Prinzip mit einer neuen Mannschaft die Mannschaft eben in der Rückrunde auch in der Liga drin behalten. Also lange Rede kurzer Sinn, er hat aus allem das Bestmögliche herausgeholt und jetzt, er sagt es selbst, er hat einfach die Chance seines Lebens jetzt bekommen bei Lazio, zum ersten Mal in einem großen Club, zum ersten Mal in einem Club mit Qualität, ja mit 61 Jahren muss man dazu sagen und er nutzt diese Chance herausragend. Lazio spielt, da wir jetzt mal Inter und Atalanta ausklammern, die das jetzt ja schon seit ein paar Jahren machen, spielt Lazio den erfrischendsten Offensiv-Fußball in der Serie A. Das ist ein Passieren so taktisch 4-2-3-1, immer mit vier Offensiven auf dem Feld, immer, er spielt eigentlich immer mit zwei Stürmern, Kassianos Dia, einer so ein bisschen hängend, über links Zarkanni, über rechts Isakson oder Pedro. Also immer mit vier klassischen Offensiven. Sehr gutes Anlaufverhalten und da muss man jetzt nochmal Gendozzi und Trovella nennen, weil das sind die Doppel-Sechs und die zwei eben sorgen halt dafür, dass die Offensiven auch glänzen können, weil die beide wahnsinnig athletisch stark sind, die decken brutal viel Raum ab. Also was Gendozzi und Trovella weglaufen, das ist herausragend. Dazu haben wir mit Nuno Tavaric, der hat ja hier auch schon mal stattgefunden, einen der herausragenden Linksverteidiger, also Tavaric plus Zaccani über links, die machen richtig Kavall. Jetzt könnte man denken, du hast so einen offensiven Linksverteidiger, dann ist dein Rechtsverteidiger so ein bisschen blockiert, schiebt ein bisschen ein. Nee, der rechte Verteidiger schiebt auch hoch an, weil die Außenverteidiger meistens bis zur Grundlune durchgehen, damit Zaccani von links und Isakson oder wer auch immer von rechts ins Zentrum reinziehen, weil das ist was, was Baroni will immer. Also der linke Außen hat seinen starken Fuß rechts, der rechte ist seinen starken Fuß links, dass die eben reinziehen können, gefährlich abschließen können, da im Zentrum nochmal überladen. Und ja, spielen einen wirklich guten Fußball, bringen brutal viel Energie mit, haben die mit Abstand meisten Tore und Assists von der Bank kommen. Also alles, was von der Bank reingeworfen wird, funktioniert. Jetzt am vergangenen Sonntag bei Neapel, sie haben gegen Neapel eben gewonnen, auswärts. Da war Rovella gesperrt, wie gesagt, einer der zentralen Spieler. Und dann hat Dele Bashirou gespielt. Weiß nicht, ob Uli den noch kennt. Der war mal in der Jugend von Man City. Und der hat halt super funktioniert, einer Seite von Gendo Si. Am Donnerstag, jetzt gestern, hat Dele Bashirou auch in der Europa League getroffen bei Ajax. Und das ist ein Kennzeichen, eben wie gesagt, alles von der Bank funktioniert. Und das finde ich ist immer ein ganz großes Zeichen dafür, wieder für einen Trainer, weil das bedeutet, a, dass er alle mitnimmt, sprich, dass alle sich Teil dieses Projekts führen und b, dass auch alle wissen, was sie zu tun haben. Und das ist wieder der nächste riesen Pluspunkt für Marco Baroni, der für ihn spricht. Und ja, also wie gesagt, wir reden hier wirklich über ein Projekt. Wir sind jetzt schon Mitte Dezember. Also ich werde jetzt weg. Wir sind jetzt nicht mehr beim Saisonstart und Lazio ist extrem gefestigt und macht einen richtig, richtig, richtig guten Job.
Aber wirklich Rang Fünf und es ist weiter in der Serie A unheimlich eng an der Spitze. Die ersten Fünfe liegen innerhalb von drei Punkten. Atalanta gerade vorne, Napoli, Inter und Florenz sind noch mit dabei. Und apropos Inter, das wird der nächste Gegner sein für Lazio. Und dann zwischen den Jahren noch Atalanta. Also ich würde sagen, absolut. Zum Ende des Jahres.
Jetzt kommen jetzt einige große, genau am Montagabend Lazio gegen Inter. Das wird besonders, Simone Insage, der Inter-Trainer, 20 Jahre bei Lazio. Und wie gesagt, Lazio, ja klar, da kommen noch einige große Spiele. Aber was mich bei Lazio jetzt mittlerweile sehr positiv stimmt, die haben eben eine ganz klare Identität, die funktionieren, die wissen, was sie zu tun haben. Klar werden da auch mal Rückschläge kommen. Aber gerade eben das vielleicht als letzten Punkt, dass Baroni es schafft, alle mitzunehmen, weil bei allen, da reden wir von 18, 19, 20 Spielern, die schon entscheidend waren oder mit entscheidend waren. Und wenn wir uns anschauen, vielleicht das Gegenbeispiel des Napoli mit Konte, da spielen im Prinzip immer die gleichen 12, 13. Und wenn dann einer oder mehrere reinkommen mal, ja, dann ist das halt oft schwierig für die, weil die logisch keine Spielpraxis haben, weil die im Prinzip ja auch vom Trainer Woche für Woche im Training mitbekommen, ja gut, ich spiel ja eh nicht. Ich spiel ja eh nur, wenn sich vielleicht einer von den Top-Leuten verletzt. Und bei Lazio ist es genau der Gegenteil, dass wirklich Barone da einen krassen Zusammenhalt schon geschaffen hat, dass eben die, die reinspringen, genau das tun, was er verlangt und die Energie mitbringen. Und dementsprechend sehe ich im Moment nicht, dass Lazio, es ist ja immer vielleicht so ein Punkt, bei Lazio und auf Joruntina könnte man jetzt vielleicht vermuten, ja gut, die haben jetzt ihre großen Wochen gehabt, in ein paar Wochen ist das wieder eingependelt. Gerade bei Lazio weiß ich nicht, ob das so kommt, weil die nehmen die Doppelbelastung wunderbar mit. Wie gesagt, das funktioniert in der Europa League auch wunderbar. Und Baroni hatte zum ersten Mal Doppelbelastung, der kannte das ja noch nie, weil überraschenderweise mit Hellas Verona und mit Lecce hat er jetzt noch nicht Doppelbelastung zu spüren bekommen, europäische. Und dementsprechend sind die so gefestigt, dass ich echt gespannt bin, wie weit es tragen kann, weil das ein sehr, sehr gutes Konstrukt ist, das da entstanden ist.
Und ich glaube, man kann sich aufs Rückspiel gegen Napoli dann in der Rückrunde schon freuen, denn wenn man zweimal Napoli mit Konte besiegt innerhalb von drei Tagen, einmal im Pokal und einmal in der Liga, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das dir nicht so komplett kalt lässt, aber es ist nur so ein loser Verdacht. Ich freue mich auf den Handshake nach dem Spiel. So und jetzt kommen wir aber zur Premier League. Uli, worüber würdest du gerne mit uns sprechen?
Es ist ja die Zeit in der Premier League im Dezember. Jetzt geht es ja richtig los erst so richtig. Das heißt, ich freue mich jetzt schon auf das, was bevorsteht. Ich kann mich gar nicht so ganz hundertprozentig entscheiden, was ich dir mitbringe. Das heißt, ich lasse dir die Wahl, wenn du magst. Es gibt paar Teams, die Probleme haben, paar Teams, von denen ich auch ehrlicherweise dachte, dass sie schon reagieren würden. Wahrscheinlich ist aber genau der Grund, dass im Moment zu viel gespielt wird und keiner sich richtig traut. Also wir könnten über Tottenham reden, sieht nicht gut aus. Wir könnten über Newcastle reden, sieht nicht gut aus. Wir könnten über sowas wie zum Beispiel die Wolves reden. Southampton ist bodenlos. Also es ist wirklich das aussichtsloseste Team in der Geschichte der Premier League, in der jüngeren zumindest, an das ich mich erinnern kann. West Ham ist wahrscheinlich ein riesengroßes Thema, weil das wahrscheinlich am unverständlichsten ist für alle, warum die da unten stehen, auch wenn die jetzt mal wieder gewonnen haben, weil es wahrscheinlich nicht alle im Verein sogar freuen wird, so doof das klingt. Ja, wahrscheinlich müssen wir uns von den Teams ansausschneiden.
Das ist doch ein Trick. Du willst doch nur, also wir können jetzt ja nicht alles abgrasen und dann sagst du, den Rest hört ihr bei Click and Rush. Ich hab sie jetzt vorweggenommen. Sehr, sehr schlau. Aber Tottenham interessiert mich tatsächlich sehr auch, weil das ja vielleicht manche Hörerinnen und Hörer mitbekommen haben, die ja jüngst erst ein sehr wildes Spiel hatten, wie man es ja auch kennt, gegen Chelsea, Kukureya rutscht zweimal aus und so weiter. Also lass mal über Tottenham sprechen. Was ist da los? Rang 11, genau die Mitte der Tabelle hat man gerade mit 20 Punkten.
Ja und am gestrigen Abend ein Spiel, das ich so unter der Endsposted Kugel noch nicht gesehen hab, weil ich sie immer zumindest energetisch erlebt habe, immer auf und ab laufend und da war gestern nichts davon zu sehen. Die Rangers müssen das Spiel eigentlich ziemlich klar gewinnen, tun sie aber nicht. Und das wird sicherlich jetzt dafür sorgen, dass das Endsposted Kugel nicht sehr viel mehr Ruhe hat. Ein Sieg in acht Spielen ist die Zahl dazu, wenngleich das ist ein 4-0 gegen Manchester City, wenngleich Nummer zwei, vielleicht jetzt nicht so aussagekräftig ist gerade. Eben, eben. Ist alles in allem so, dass ich zu Beginn der Saison, nee ich muss noch weiter vorne anfangen, das ist weiterhin und das ist glaube ich zu dem Zeitpunkt der Entwicklung nicht das, was man gerne gesagt hätte über dieses Team, weiterhin das unberechenbarste Team der Liga. Du weißt nie, was du kriegst. Also es ist mal eine Leistung drin, wo man denkt, ja genau, das ist genau was wir wollen und dann gibt es wieder eine Leistung, wo man sich einfach nur verwundert die Augen greift. Aber auch innerhalb eines Spiels, du hast jetzt Chelsea schon angesprochen, da war es mir klar, als ich das gesehen hab, hab es auch noch getwittert, das dauert jetzt 30 Minuten und dann steht es hier 2-3. Und genauso war es dann auch am Ende.
Zu Hause, nach 2-0 Führung mit dazu zu sagen.
Das ist total normal, weil, und das ist Teil meines Vorwurf, sein Anspors de Couglo, der lässt die, der Anspor, den wir letztes Jahr hier auch mal besprochen haben, also wirklich auf und ab, das hat er fast noch auf die Spitze getrieben in der Saison, zeigen auch die Transfers, die gemacht worden sind, die sind a, alle super jung, bis auf vielleicht den einzigen, der so als Exot raussticht, das ist auch gleichzeitig der Rekord-Transfer, Dominic Solenki, aber der Rest sind eigentlich Projekte für die Zukunft und sie passen perfekt rein ins System. Das klingt jetzt erstmal wichtig wie ein Vorwurf, ist aber insofern einer, dass Poste Koglo nur dieses eine System spielen lässt und nichts anderes. Das ist dauernd und das in der Premier League im übrigen, gegen zum Teil sehr kontrollierende und kontrollierte Teams. In England sagt man Gang-How, also einfach nur rauf, runter, rauf, runter, rauf, runter. Und häufig geht das halt nicht so gut aus. Das zweite ist, ja okay, in der Spitze haben sie diesen Aingeball gestärkt, aber in der Breite ist halt so gut wie gar nichts da. Fandeven und Romero kommen beide zurück gegen Chelsea nach Verletzung, verletzen sich im Spiel. Das ist natürlich auch super bitter, dass da grad vieles zusammenkommt, verletzen sich im Spiel gleich wieder und sind halt absolut nicht zu ersetzen. Das spielt jetzt gestern Archie Gray, der eigentlich als erste Position Sechser geholt wird, als zweite Position, da hat er aber schon keinen Bock drauf, Rechtsverteidiger. Und jetzt muss der gestern Innenverteidiger spielen, der ist ein Teenager, der bis dato zweite Liga gespielt hat. Auf der Sechs, das weiß ich aus einer sehr gut unterrichteten Quelle, hat Endsposs de Couglo abgewingt und sich nett bedankt, dass man ihm gerne jemanden gegeben hätte, sagt er, oh nö, F. Summa passt für mich. Das ist genau der, den ich brauche. Ja, aber du bräuchst jetzt halt zwei, drei andere noch. Auch da, wenn die gestern dann wechseln entsprechend, dann kommen halt drei Achter rein. Und er hat nicht einen Sechser. Pierre-Emil Heuber aber schön nach draußen begleitet nach Marseille, der ja zumindest im Kader war. Der nicht hundertprozentig passt, ist mir klar. Der aber letzte Saison, ich müsste jetzt lügen, aber zumindest in der Liga, glaube ich, in jedem Spiel gespielt hat. Nicht von Beginn an, aber immer eingewechselt worden ist, was ja schon zeigt, dass sie ihn gebraucht haben und genutzt haben. Ja, und dann gibt es eigentlich nur einen, der so richtig gut in Form ist. Der hat dafür einen riesen Schritt gemacht und der auch konstant in Form ist. Das ist der Kulusevski. Je nach Rechnung könnte man den in die Top 3 oder 5 Spieler der aktuellen Premier League Saison packen. Heißt aber auch, all die anderen, die da so rumlaufen, sind nicht konstant. Kein Madison, kein Sonn, der gerade echt eine schwache Phase auch vorm Tor vor allen Dingen hat. Gibt auch Gerüchte, dass es da nicht hundertprozentig passt hinter den Kulissen, dass da eventuell auch sogar ein Abgang im Raum steht. Keine Vertragsverlängerung. Über Pizuma schon gesprochen, der spielte dann himmelhoch, jaucht, sind super. Und dann zieht man ihn einfach drei Wochen gar nicht. Destiny Udogi habe ich nie so schwach gesehen wie gerade. Das liegt nicht daran, dass das nicht kann, sondern ich glaube, der ist einfach so, so übermüdet, weil der rauf und runter laufen muss. Der hat gestern sich einfach fünf, sechs Sprints gespart. Und dann, Christian weiß das dann schon, dann kann man eigentlich sagen, okay, gib ihm mal eine Woche Urlaub. Vicarrio nicht da, der wird bis März wohl ausfallen. Bin mal gespannt, ob sie da was tun. Auf der Position fehlt an allen Ecken und Enden, auch wenn es Fraser Forster so weit so gut macht, aber ist natürlich wesentlich zu wenig. Timo Werner gerade wieder, der ist so bitter, weil ich noch vor einer Woche gesagt hab, ach, das ist seine wahrscheinlich beste Phase bei Tottenham. Dann spielt der gestern ein Spiel, keine Ahnung woher es kommt und dann sagt auch Postel Koglo hinterher in den Gesprächen, fehlt Interviews, ja das ist nicht akzeptabel und das habe ich ihm auch genauso gesagt. So geht es die ganze Zeit rauf und runter, rauf und runter, rauf und runter. Ich weiß auch schon, dass bei Tottenham längst nicht mehr alle hinter Ainge Postel Koglo so richtig stehen. Komischerweise hat der starke Mann da, Johann Lange, aber alles so eingekauft, dass Ainge Ball weiter gespielt wird. Ich tippe nur, dass der bereit wäre, das Ainge vor dem Ball zu streichen. Das ist so mein Gefühl.
Ganz kurz, Uli, ist schön zu hören, dass es nicht nur in Italien den Achterbahn-Effekt gibt. Da würde ich jetzt Milan einfach reinwerfen, bei denen vieles ähnlich läuft mit diesem rauf und runter immer. Ja, viele Spitzen, viele Tiefen. Nicht gut für eine Mannschaft, wenn man über eine Saison lang konstant was erreichen will.
Etwas Kontrolle ist manchmal gut.
Aber habt ihr denn bei Nils nicht zugehört? Also Uli, du konntest noch nicht zuhören, du warst noch nicht da. Aber Nils hat uns doch gerade erst vorhin erklärt, wie gut es ist, manchmal an einem Trainer festzuhalten mit Athletik, Bilbao. Und das wäre jetzt dann auch mal eine Frage zu Ange Posticciuclo. Also den kennen ja Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen schon sehr lange, denn Thomas Bräuch spricht in den allerhöchsten Tönen von ihm und im entsprechenden Tribüngespräch haben wir auch darüber geredet. Und da hat er eben auch erklärt, dass damals Posticciuclo ihn eben versucht hat, sie spielen zu lassen wie Barca mit den Mitteln, die sie hatten. Also sprich ein ballbesitzorientierter Fußball und das hat er ja bei seinen Stationen dann weiter so vorangetrieben. Was ich aber bisher nicht so auf dem Schirm hatte, bis zu diesem Spiel, wo sie zu neunt immer noch an der Mittellinie die Abseitslinie gestellt haben, weiß gar nicht mehr gegen wen das war. Da was ich nicht auf dem Schirm hatte, war eben einfach...
Jesse, oder?
Ja, ich glaube auch, dass es Jesse war, ja. Was sie dann hinten raus, was ja auch ganz lange funktioniert hat. Aber du hast ja auch dieses hin und her besprochen. Und das ist ja quasi das, was man ihm vorwerfen kann. Offensiv passiert was, aber definitiv auch immer etwas. Und das ist ja aber eine Komponente, die beim Barca der Guardiola Jahre immer mit dabei war, dass du über den Ballbesitz auch Spielkontrolle hattest und über das Gegenpressing, die dir einfach diese Konter nicht gefangen hast. Ist das jetzt ein Glitch in der Matrix, dass das nicht funktioniert in dieser Saison? Lässt Posto Choclo dann doch einen anderen Fußball spielen? Also woran liegt das deiner Meinung nach?
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, ob er es anders spielen lässt. Vermutlich schon auch. Aber es ist ziemlich klar erkennbar, dass sämtliche Positionierungen vor den etwaigen Ballverlusten, also du hast ja ganz oft die Situation, du spielst ja nicht immer, du hast den Ball, der Gegner bekommt ihn und macht dann was, sondern es geht ja oftmals auch hin und her. Und da ist genau das Problem. Also sie gehen ordentlich ins Gegenpressing, manchmal werden sie auch da schon überspielt, aber sagen wir mal sie gehen ordentlich ins Gegenpressing, sind dann aber schon ungeordnet am Ball, haben keine Struktur, spielen den Ball wieder dem Gegner zu und ab, dann sind die völlig am Ende. Und da sind sie wahrscheinlich das schwächste Team der ganzen Liga. Und da fangen die sich wahnsinnig viel, dazu kommen halt dann auch noch ein paar individuelle Fehler, die hohe Verteidigungslinie, die du schon angesprochen hast. Wenn Van de Ween nicht wäre, der eine relativ gute Saison spielt, ich würde sogar sagen wahrscheinlich sogar unter den Top fünf bis zehn Verteidigern ist, bis er verletzt war in der Premier League. Wenn der aber nicht schon einiges abgelaufen hätte mit seinem absoluten Speed, dann hätten die noch mehr Gegentore, was eigentlich schon gar nicht mehr geht. Aber ja, das ist glaube ich so der Hauptgrund, warum es da nicht funktioniert, dass er immer noch dabei ist, der teilweise mit sieben in letzter Linie gespielt, was hoch unterhaltsam ist. Alles gut und sie haben auch, das muss man nicht mehr auch lassen, sie haben Dominic Zolenki identifiziert als Pressingspieler, sodass sie dieses System auf die Spitze treiben können, gegen den Ball erstmal drauf zu rumpeln. Aber mir geht es halt eher darum, ich hätte gerne zum Beispiel eine 6 oder dann auch eine 8, oder auch der eingezogene, der inverse Glückl-Verteidiger, wie zum Beispiel Destin Yudogi, der dann halt auch mal stehen bleiben darf und aber auch eine gewisse Größe hat, eine gewisse Athletik hat, um umgegen zu arbeiten. Bisuma ist der Typ Spieler, der zur Ballsicher ist und der hat theoretisch auch Abfängerqualitäten, aber der muss ja so viel Raum covern, das wird nicht funktionieren in der Premier League. Das ist das große Thema und wesentlicher Punkt auch ist, und ich glaube das ist wirklich ein wesentlicher Punkt in dem Fall, Ainge hat die ganze Zeit zu Beginn der letzten Saison sehr positiv gesprochen. Das ist genau das, was die gebraucht haben bei Tottenham, nach Konter. Also sie haben irgendjemanden gebraucht, der irgendetwas Positives sagt und bringt und tut. Und selbst als es angefangen hat so nach acht, neun Runden nicht mehr so zu laufen, immer noch positiv gesprochen, eine Idee verkauft, alles in Ordnung. Und dann gab es ja auch schon noch mal zwei, drei Einbrüche in der Saison, gerade hinten raus. Und da fing es an. Da ist er echt negativ geworden, hat geschimpft, hat sich teilweise angelegt, sagt auch manchmal echt dumme Sätze, muss man ehrlich sagen. Der ist glaube ich noch gewohnt an den kleineren Märkten sagen zu dürfen, was er will. Die werden den gladenlos aufs Boot gestrichen in England. Das ist ja logisch. Sowas wie, ja normalerweise gewinne ich in meiner zweiten Saison Silber. Na, lieber nicht machen mit der Sonne im Rücken. Das ist nicht so clever. Und jetzt ist er gerade, wirkt er sehr grumpy. Und das wird etwas sein, das ihm glaube ich am Ende zum Verhängnis werden könnte. Also Platz 11 in der Premier League ist viel zu wenig. Vor allen Dingen, wenn man sich die Spielverläufe anschaut. Jetzt in der Europa League, okay, haben sie immer noch einen Punkt geholt. Das müsste wahrscheinlich schon reichen. Da haben sie auch weitestgehend mit der B11 gespielt. Das passt schon. Aber die müssen auch auf jeden Fall was tun auf dem Markt. Und müssten vielleicht noch mal so einen Schritt zurück von der extremen Mischung, die sie gerade haben, hin zu ein, zwei erfahrenere, die auch passen werden, werfen.
Ach, Ange, ich bin gespannt, wie es da weitergeht. Er hat ja allein durch den Thomas-Vorreuch-Bezug immer einen Platz in meinem Herzen gehabt. Was auch Platz in meinem Herzen hat, ist unsere Runde, in der wir noch mal kleinere Themen ansprechen, etwas kürzer. Also Themen, Personen, die euch besonders aufgefallen sind, Spieler, Trainer haben wir da immer gerne mit dabei. Nies, du darfst gerne mal loslegen, wer wäre denn der erste Spieler, der erste Trainer, den du ins Rampenlicht drücken würdest?
Hätte auch das ganze Team sein können mit Blick auf die Tabelle, aber da habe ich mich für den Athletic Club entschieden, weil es dann doch bei meinem anderen Team einen Spieler gibt, der noch ein bisschen mehr hervorsteht. Und ja, das ist Antoine Griesmann bei Atletico. Wie gesagt, die sind auch ziemlich gut drauf, allein in den letzten fünf Spielen 21 Tore gemacht. Ja, das ist, wir reden wirklich von Atletico Madrid. Und die hatten einen holprigen Saisonstart, wo auch viele Neuzugänge kamen. Ein paar Alte sind gegangen, ein paar Neue kamen in der vorn und hinten. Da gab es noch ein paar wackelige Sachen, nicht immer die perfekten Ergebnisse. Simeone teilweise noch doch zu passiv spielen lassen oder typisch Simeone-like. Ja, und jetzt haben sie einfach mal zehn Siege in Folge eingefahren. Am Wochenende gab es ein wirklich spektakuläres 4 zu 3 Sieg gegen Sevilla. Da lag man noch in der 60. Minute mit 1-3 zurück. Und natürlich Antoine Grießmann da in den Doppelpack geschnürt. In Weisselied waren sie auswärts, haben gewonnen. Da wurde er mit Applaus vom Platz verabschiedet. Also das ist ja auch eine große Geste. Jetzt natürlich auch gegen Bratislava zwei Tore gemacht. Also Antoine Grießmann ist da weiter sehr viel für eine Mannschaft, die einfach qualitativ viel zugelegt hat. Julian Alvarez funktioniert. Ich würde fast sagen, dass Diego Simeone auch profitiert vom vielleicht breitesten Kader der Liga, dass er auch mal in Angril Correa reinbringen kann, der nicht unglücklich ist, wenn er weiter auf der Bank sitzt, aber trotzdem noch viele Tore nach der 90. Minute macht. Und einfach für Simeone ist auch Antoine Grießmann einfach ein wichtiger Spieler, so verlängerte Arme auf dem Platz, der auch die Kommandos weitergeben kann. Die sind auch privat sehr eng zusammen und mittlerweile hat da jetzt auch Grießmann Geschichte geschrieben. In diesem Jahrtausend gibt es nur noch drei Spieler, die mehr Punkte für ihre Mannschaften beschert haben. Auf zwei Namen kommt ja alle bestimmt, nämlich Messi und Cristiano natürlich. Cristiano hat jetzt 132 Punkte für Real beschert. Grießmann steht jetzt bei 131. In der Mitte ist da noch Raúl und Grießmann hat jetzt frisch Benzemaar beholt. Also und Grießmann hat auch noch einiges im Tank. Also aktuell ist das eine Saison, wo sich Atletico auch so jetzt an Real und Barca rangeschlichten hat. Der Abstand ist nicht mehr groß, nur noch ein Punkt hinter Real. Die haben ein Spiel weniger und drei hinter Barca. Von dem ist da auch Atletico generell durchaus sehr erwähnenswert. Der Fußball stimmt auch, es ist furios, offensiv. Es ist mit Risiko mittlerweile nicht nur Absicherung. Die Auswärtsschwäche haben sie abgelegt und inmitten von all dem Wahnsinn ist ein Antoine Grießmann, der da einfach für sehr viel steht und einfach auch pure Torgefahr ist, immer noch die Qualität hat und absolute Weltklasse ist.
Dessen wievielter Frühling ist das eigentlich? Oder liegt das einfach nur darin, weil man ihn notorisch unterschätzt?
Auch ein bisschen, auch ein bisschen. Also er hatte auf jeden Fall die zwei Jahre in Barcelona, das heißt, haben sie nicht gutgetan, war ein Missverständnis, sondern ist er zurückgekehrt und dann auch schnell wieder in die Spur gefunden. Und einfach also es ist jetzt auch nicht das erste Mal, dass Atletico auch ein bisschen riskanter Spiel, das ist schon die letzten ein, zwei Jahre immer mal aufgetaucht. Und auch da war ein Kriegsmann immer vorne mit dabei und war nicht vorletztes Jahr sogar bei uns, bei Tiki Taka, der Spieler der Saison. Also ja, es ist einfach ein zweiter sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr langer und auch schöner Frühling.
Ich wollte noch ein paar Frühlingsmeer, nur weil es gerade beim Nils reinpasst, weil ich vorhin den Namen vergessen habe. Den muss man bei Lazio auch nennen. Was Pedro in dieser Saison auch wieder macht, ist herausragend. Also wirklich, ja, nur so zum Thema, weil ich gerade Frühling höre. Ich glaube, hier ist ein sehr lang gezogener Frühling.
Gut, ich glaube bei Chris Mann kommt natürlich auch noch die Nationalteam-Karriere mit dazu, wo man auch jetzt vor allem jetzt natürlich nach dem Ende im Nationalteam dann vor allem noch mal auf die Leistungen zurückblickt. Er hat doch seine Karriere beendet, oder? Du hast gerade so kritisch geguckt. Nee, ist doch, wenn ich mich da jetzt...
Ich bin jetzt nicht mehr so sicher, aber...
Okay, alles klar. Die Hörerinnen und Hörer können mich korrigieren. Es ist gerade leider alles sehr wild. Mein Handy dreht hier auch gleich durch. Muss ich gleich gucken, ob das der lang erwartete Mensch ist, wem ihr wisst, dass wir hier schon später angefangen haben. Aber erst will ich hören, was Daniel denn noch so mitgebracht hat.
Ja, ich habe, wie auch Uli, schon so ein bisschen so Entscheidungs-Fügigkeiten, welche Themen ich denn gerne präsentieren möchte. Ich hab mich dann für eins entschieden, aber ich möchte erst das andere Kostüm mal anreißen, weil ich finde, dass Arnels Musa von Feyenoord es verdient hat, auch nochmal auf ein Drogensatz zu kommen. Der hat die letzten drei, vier Spiele in der Liga schon getroffen, hat jetzt auch in der CL für Feyenoord getroffen gegen Prag und er hat einfach einen großen Anteil daran, dass bei Feyenoord auch wieder ein bisschen Ruhe eingekänt ist, dass sich das Team stabilisiert hat. Der ist ein Offensivspieler, spielt in voller Reihe bei Feyenoord, hat auch gegen Prag jetzt in der CL ein wunderschönes Robin-Manier-Tour erzählt von so einem schönen Schlänzer außerhalb der Strafraums. Und da macht es einfach Spaß, dem zuzusehen. Der hat eine tolle Technik, tolle Triplings und das wollte ich nicht unerwähnt lassen. Aber mein eigentlicher Spieler, den ich Ihnen mal erwähnen wollte, ist von den legendären Go Ahead Eagles Deventer. Ich nehme gerne auch kleinere Vereine aus der Liga ins Repertoire. Und das ist der Norweger Oliver Edvardsen. Und das ist wirklich der MVP von den Go Ahead Eagles, Oli Ditton. Der hat die ersten fünf Spiele gefehlt bei Deventer und hat deswegen nur zehn auch gemacht. Und in diesen zehn Spielen aber sieben Tore erzielt. Und daran merkt man dann schon, dass er durchaus Faktor ist für die Go Ahead Eagles. Der hat jetzt gegen Neumehren am Wochenende auch einen Dreierpack erzielt. Die haben nach 25 Minuten von 4-0 geführt, Deventer. Und da hat er in der fünften, sechsten und 25. Minute die Tore erzielt. Und das ist einfach nur, der macht auch extrem viel Spaß. Und die Spielanlage von den Go Ahead Eagles, die kommt ihm auch, wie ich finde, zu gut. Das ist eine Mannschaft, die auch Spaß macht, die sehr viel Risiko geht. Die gewinnen auch mal fünf Minuten jetzt gegen Neumehren. Die verlieren dann wieder 5-1 gegen Feyenoord. Dann gewinnen sie wieder 4-1 gegen Heracles. Und 0-0 gab es noch nie in der Saison.
Also sie bleiben ihr Namen treu. Ich meine, sie sind ja nicht die Bilder Wall Eagles.
Auf gar keinen Fall, die sind das Gegenteil. Die haben die Abwehrkette hinten, verteidigt generell gerne mal sehr hoch, was sie dann auch wieder anfällig macht für diverse Konter und zum Beispiel spielen. Aber sie sind mutig, sie ziehen das Spiel generell breit auf und sehr flügellastig. Und Edvardsson kommt dann auch gut in diese 1-2-1-Duelle, die ja dann auch gerne mal gewinnt mit Feindtriplings. Und das passt sehr gut, it's a match, würde man sagen. Und der ist übrigens, nicht zu verwechseln, mit Viktor Edvardsson, der spielt da auch, der ist aber Schwede, ist auch Stürmer. Aber genau, die beiden Edvardsons vorne bei den Go-Hat Eagles sind für die Go-Hat Eagles Gold wert, vor allem Oliver. Und die stehen auch recht gut da, sind jetzt 8er in der Tabelle. Und werden Wörtchen mitreden über die Quali von 6 bis 9 in der Rallye Visi, hatten ja Chancen auf eine EL-Quali. Und das wird eventuell machen und vor allem auch, ich find's immer schön, wenn so ein offensiver Ansatz, der auch mal in die Hose gehen kann, wie bei den 5-1 gegen Feyenoord dann doch belohnt wird in der Summe.
Weißt du, wär das auch. Marc, Ange Postetjoklung, Marc. Wenn genau das passiert. Edvardsen übrigens, wenn ich das jetzt hier richtig nebenher recherchiert habe, noch nicht für die norwegische Nationalmannschaft im Herrenbereich nominiert worden. Was ist da los? Hören die nicht die Liga Tour? Offensichtlich.
War mal kurz davor.
War mal kurz davor?
Er hatte, ich hab er, sehr gut. Ich hab aufgrund von familiären Anhangs in Norwegen so einen kleinen Soft-Spot für Valerenga. Und irgendwie meine Neffen, die bringen mir immer gerne was mit von da. Und da hat er gespielt zwischen 17 und 19. Da war kurz davor, da galt ja das Next Big Thing. Ist ein super Athlet. Guter Junge. Und auch übrigens für Konsolenspieler. Das ist so jemand, den könnte man auf dem Schirm haben.
Wahnsinn. Das ist ja was man hier für Sachen nebenher erfährt. Ich erinnere mich an die Supermarkt-Geschichte in Monaco von Uli. Jetzt wissen wir Valerenga Bezug. Da weiß ich auch, dass du bei den FC Bayern Frauen genau hingeguckt hast, denn die haben ja gegen Valerenga gespielt in der Champions League. Unentschieden, auswärts und zu Hause gewonnen. Jetzt gestern gegen Juve, 4 zu 0 gewonnen. Fantastisch.
Die Männer sind üblerweise einfach abgestiegen. Das ist unmöglich, dass du mit der Größe in Oslo, in den norwegischen Liga absteigst. Ich sag, Jungs erklärt mir mal was da los ist. Ist ja unmöglich. Aber ja, kann man nichts machen.
Okay, also wenn du willst, dann machen wir mal ein Norwegen-Special hier in der Ligatur. Das können wir gerne demnächst mal machen.
Das glaube ich, das würde ich mir jetzt nicht zutrauen, was ich dazu sagen kann.
Also wir haben die Go Ahead Eagles-Devente. Ich freue mich jetzt schon aufs Raussuchen des Logos fürs Thumbnail, für solche Media und bei YouTube. Es sieht einfach ganz fantastisch aus. Christian, jetzt bin ich gespannt, wie du da nachlegen willst.
Ja, ich bringe die Geschichte eigentlich aus Italien mit der letzten zwei Wochen, die Gott sei Dank gut ausgegangen ist, nämlich Eduardo Bove. Da müssen wir logischerweise noch ein paar Worte verlieren. War ja der vorletzte Spieltag, Fiorentina gegen Inter. Und ich glaube in der 15. oder 16. Minute musste er abgebrochen werden, weil Bove auf dem Feld zusammengesackt ist. Und, weiß nicht, alle, die es vielleicht gesehen haben, also die Angst in den Augen aller Spieler drum herum, die hat, ja, hat schon sehr viel erzählt. Also ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, ich hab das gesehen, ich hab das von Eriksen auch gesehen. Und ich hatte in dem Moment ein schlechteres Gefühl als bei Christian Eriksen, weil da wirklich viele, ja, es war sehr emotional. Das Gute ist, Gott sei Dank, es ist unter Anführungszeichen gut ausgegangen. Also Bove musste ja in Krankenwagen reanimiert werden. Ist dann auf die Intensivstation gekommen und konnte aber, Gott sei Dank, ich glaube, zwei Tage darauf gab es schon mal die erste Entwarnung, also dass es keine lebensbedrohlichen Situationen waren. Und jetzt mittlerweile ist es so, dass er jetzt Ende der Woche das Krankenhaus verlassen kann. Hat jetzt Anfang der Woche einen Herzschrittmacher eingesetzt bekommen. Dazu muss man sagen, der könnte rein theoretisch noch ausgenommen werden. Also das ist kein Fixer sozusagen. Aber die große Frage ist jetzt logischerweise, wie geht es für ihn weiter? Es gibt noch keine, der wird jetzt logischerweise noch die nächsten Monate beobachtet. Es gibt auch noch kein komplett klinisches Bild sozusagen, was da genau der Auslöser war. Aber es deutet logischerweise sehr viel jetzt in die Richtung hin, wie es halt auch bei Christian Eriksen ging. Nämlich, falls dieser Herzschrittmacher drin bleiben sollte, dann dürfte er in Italien nicht mehr spielen. Das war ja damals auch, Italien hat damit die strengsten Regeln medizinisch, was dieses Thema betrifft in ganz Europa. Und bei Christian Eriksen war es ja damals auch, er war damals Interspieler und dann war klar, dass er seine Karriere in Italien nicht mehr fortsetzen konnte, kann sie ja Gott sei Dank in England fortsetzen. Und das ist jetzt alles eine Sache, die wird sich bei Borwe in den nächsten Wochen, Monaten entscheiden. Aber erstmal das Allerwichtigste ist wirklich, dass es ihm gut geht, weil wie gesagt die Szenen waren schon sehr, sehr, sehr erdrückend und dementsprechend es geht ihm gut. Er hat jetzt schon öfter auch schon mit der Mannschaft telefoniert, hat die Spiele gesehen in der Mannschaft. Es gibt so Berichte, die sagen Menschen, die ihm nahestehen, dass er gar nicht verstanden hat. Dieser ganze Trubel, das war ihm alles zu viel. Auch dieses Mediale, weil es wirklich in Italien ein riesen Thema war. Auch mit der Vorgeschichte logisch in Florenz. Da erinnern sich vielleicht noch ein paar David Astori, der ehemalige Kapitän, der ja im Hotel vor einigen Jahren verstorben ist. Und in Italien gab es letztes Jahr die Szene mit einem Dika, der ja der Roma-Spieler, der in Udine zusammengebrochen ist. Also er ist in Italien schon, wie soll man sagen, ja große Awareness in die Richtung. Und deswegen, ja, das Wichtigste ist Eduardo Borbe, geht es soweit gut und ja, was seine zukünftige Karriere betrifft, wird man sich einfach in den nächsten Monaten anschauen müssen. Er will unbedingt spielen, das fehlt da draus. Aber ja, ich glaube, da wird man noch ein bisschen Geduld haben müssen. Und das Schöne ist, abschließend die Fiorentina hat zwar das erste Spiel danach. Im Pokal sind sie leider ausgeschieden, im Elfmeterschießen gegen Empoli, aber jetzt in der Liga haben sie wieder gewonnen, war der achte Sieg in Folge. Logischerweise das ganze Stadion, alles nur Richtung Borwe. Und das 1-0 hat Cataldi gemacht, sein engster Kumpel, der hat ihm auch auf dem Feld gleich zusammen mit Cialeluno, da war der erste, der erste Hilfe geleistet hat, der ihm auch die Zunge quasi aus dem Mundraum da quasi die Zunge zur Seite gelegt hat, weil da ja am Anfang immer auch die Erstickungsgefahr betrifft, der wirklich schnell reagiert hat. Und Cataldi macht das Tor und rennt Richtung Kamera und zeigt die Vier und schickt ein Küsschen. Also ja, waren schon sehr, sehr emotionale letzten 14 Tage in Florenz und auch für Fußball die Tage.
Ja, hat man ja auch hier mitbekommen. Wird denn das in irgendeiner Art und Weise thematisiert, dass diese Regeln der Serie A, die nachvollziehbar sind, aber für Spieler ja brutal sein können? Ich meine, das ist ein gebürtiger Römer, er ist 22 Jahre alt, sein Beruf ist das Fußballspielen. Ich will nicht damit sagen, dass ich die Regel falsch finde oder so. Da steht mir gar nicht zu. Aber wird darüber diskutiert, dass es ja quasi ein Berufsverbot im italienischen Spitzensport für ihn bedeutet und er damit ins Ausland, wenn er weiterspielen möchte, gezwungen wird?
Es wird sogar ganz interessanterweise, ich hab das auch sehr aufmerksam beobachtet, schon damals bei Eriksen jetzt wieder. Eigentlich aus medizinischer Sicht wird sogar von der anderen Seite aufgezogen, dass sich sehr viele italienische Sportmediziner fragen, warum in den anderen Ländern nicht die Regeln auch so stringent sind. Weil viele Sportmediziner einfach sagen, das ist ein extrem heikles Risiko, dass du eingehst, wenn du einem Spieler, der schon mal einen Patholog oder halt irgendeinem Herzthema hatte, dass der dann teilweise wieder weiterspielen kann. Also ich übertrage euch, bringe euch jetzt nur die medizinische Sicht mit, dass viele Sportmediziner eigentlich eher die Frage stellen in Italien, warum darf der noch woanders spielen? Oder warum kriegt er woanders die Ideenität? Also es ist glaube ich ein, ja, also ich bin da nicht so tief drin, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, was das ganze medizinische eben betrifft. Fakt ist, Italien ist da so streng und wird da auch nicht weggehen. Gerade eben mit der Vorgeschichte der letzten Jahre. Und dementsprechend, ich weiß, was du meinst, Max, mir ging es logisch auch so, wenn ich jetzt denke, der dürfte überall anders spielen, nur in Italien nicht, dann kann man definitiv fragen, warum in Italien nicht. Und auf der anderen Seite ist ja vielleicht schon ein Teil der Antwort, er dürfte ja woanders spielen. Und dann wär es ja nicht mehr de facto ein Berufsverbot für ihn sozusagen komplett, sondern halt einfach ein lokalbegrenztes. Ich werfe euch noch eine Frage rein, die mir gekommen ist, die ich auch gar nicht beantworten kann. Ich wüsste gar nicht, wie es jetzt wäre, wenn er, sag mal, er würde nach England gehen, weiterspielen und er würde Nationalspieler werden, dann könnte ich euch jetzt gar nicht sagen, ob er zum Beispiel bei Heimspielen in Italien für die Nationalmannschaft auflaufen dürfte, aber eben für Italien, wenn die auswärts in England spielen. Also das kam bei mir jetzt nur mal so auf, wie das dann gehandhabt würde, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Aber Fakt ist, ich glaube, er wird alles dafür tun, wieder Fußball zu spielen und ich sag mal, gerade der Art Spielertyp wäre er war, auch bei der Fiorentinerwahl, er wirklich ein wichtiger Faktor für diese Fiorentinerwahl, ein wahnsinnig intensiver, laufstarker Spieler ist, würde ich dieses Premier League-Thema gar nicht komplett ausklammern. Also wenn der sich vielleicht wirklich wieder fängt, körperlich, dann wäre der vielleicht wirklich einer für Ekland, der da auch Fuß fassen könnte. Aber ich glaube, das ist jetzt sehr weit in die Zukunft reingeschätzt.
Ganz interessantes Thema. Also auch mit durchaus Beispielen dieser gibt es, gibt den garnalischen Spieler, da war Mena, der hat beim Medizincheck bei Brighton in Haft, das ist schon fünf, sechs Jahre her, haben die auch Herzprobleme festgestellt. Deswegen wurde er nicht verpflichtet und ich kürze jetzt ein bisschen ab. Er war dann später auch in Spanien und dann in der Schweiz und da hat sich ein Herzschrittmacher einsetzen lassen, der ihm nach dem, was damals bekannt war, angeblich auch während eines Spiels das Leben mutmaßlich gerettet hat. Er hat ihn sich allerdings entfernen lassen danach, weil er weiter Fußball spielen wollte und der damalige Verein gesagt hat, dieses Risiko ist uns zu hoch, ist dann später in die albanische Liga gewechselt und dort tatsächlich kollabiert und auf dem Weg ins Krankenhaus gestorben. Und gerade das, was du gesagt hast, die Sicht der Mediziner und Medizinerinnen darauf, warum eigentlich wir das in anderen Ligen nicht haben. Es ist eine total interessante Debatte, weil da kommst du letztlich auf individuelle Freiheit, auf Selbstbestimmung, aber eben auch auf gesellschaftliche Fürsorge. Großes Thema. Ich bin gespannt, wie das weitergeht. Auch die Diskussion dazu.
Sorry, ganz kurz ein letzter Satz noch dazu. Also in Italien dadurch, dass er, er könnte, Paul, er könnte ihn sich auch selbst rausnehmen, wie gesagt. Das ist seine Entscheidung. Aber ich möchte, das kann ich jetzt schon ausschließen. Es wird in Italien keinen Sportarzt geben, der ihm dann sozusagen das Zertifikat aufstellt. Also auch selbst wenn der sich jetzt rausnimmt und vielleicht wirklich medizinisch belegbar wäre, dass es okay ist, würde ich fast ausschließen, dass der weiterhin in Italien spielt. Weil irgendein Arzt muss dann bei der sportärztlichen Visite die Verantwortung übernehmen. Und in Italien wird das keiner übernehmen. Das glaube ich kann man jetzt schon sagen.
Interessantes Thema. Total spannendes Thema. Aber das Allerwichtigste ist, dass es ihm gut geht. Die Gesundheit besteht über allem und wir wünschen ihm, dass er immer gesund bleibt, egal für welchen Lebensweg er sich dann selbst entscheidet. Uli, ich weiß, dass dein Korb noch voll ist mit dem. Was ziehst du jetzt raus?
Auch da, ich könnte jetzt theoretisch über Michael Antonio erzählen, soll man vielleicht mal gehört haben, der ist am Samstag schwer verunglückt. Ich glaube nicht in Zusammenhang mit dem Sturmtief Dara, aber weiß ich nicht. Die Westerm hat darum gebeten, dass man nicht im Privatreben rumschnüffelt und auch ansonsten nicht kommentiert, ob es gut oder schlecht steht. Daran möchte ich mich gerne halten. Alles, was wir wissen ist und die Bilder sind ja leider Gottes gelegt worden, wo immer. Ich habe das leider auch gesehen, wenn man manchmal in seinem Feed solche Dinge nicht verhindern kann. Alles Beste weiterhin an der Stelle, glaube ich, kann er brauchen. Ich würde wahrscheinlich gerne, das wäre jetzt kein Thema, das ich geeignet hätte, um es ganz groß aufzuziehen, aber ganz kurz auf Crystal Palace blicken, die nämlich klammerheimlich über den Strich geklettert sind, nicht mehr in der Abstiegszone stehen und ich glaube, eine Niederlage in den letzten sieben haben, glaube ich. Auf jeden Fall ist er drei nicht mehr in der Premier League verloren haben, haben sogar zwei Punkte gegen Manchester City liegen lassen und haben aber auch zwischenzeitlich mal wieder gewonnen und bei denen ist es so, dass die immer wieder war das so ein Thema. Viele Spieler, der Großteil des Kaders ist entweder verkauft worden, Michael Ulyse, oder spät war klar, dass er da bleiben würde. Die haben den großen, tatsächlich einen Kern für Englands Nationalteam gestellt, in Worten in Esse, in Geyhi. Die sind spät zurückgekommen, Mateta spät von Olympia zurückgekommen, Munoz, Cop America. Das heißt, die Schlüsselspieler sind sehr spät und mit komplett unterschiedlicher Form, sowohl mental als auch was das körperlich betrifft, zurückgekommen. Da hatte Glasner große Schwierigkeiten, die reinzubekommen. Die haben die ersten zwei, drei Saisonmonate keine Intensität gebracht. Dadurch, zumindest sagt er das so, klingt aber auch einigermaßen logisch, viele individuelle Fehler produziert und am Ball eigentlich noch nicht mal sich beschäftigt, irgendwas zu tun. Und Purple, steigen die in den Sprint, in den intensiven Läufen. Statistiken sind in den letzten Wochen schon, zumindest bei den Sprints, Top 3 wieder und siehe da, sie sind wieder schwieriger zu besiegen, was aber muss man fairerweise sagen, also sie sind nie abgeschossen worden. Das war zu allermeist waren es Niederlagen mit einem Tor. Differenz könnte auch einen Fall aufmachen, dass man sagt, hätten die ihr zweites Spiel, glaube ich, war es gegen Brentford, da gab es ein aberkanntes Tor. Wenn die das machen, gibt es vielleicht sogar eine Dynamik los. So ist es jetzt eher negativ, Dynamik geworden, dann wie immer, aber Reggie Essay mal verletzt und so weiter und so weiter. Aber langsam und sicher sind die wieder ein richtig hässlich zu spielendes Team. Und glaube ich, haben sich ganz gut positioniert, dass sie im Abstiegskampf dann ordentlich mit dabei sind. Also wir haben jetzt schon plus vier auf die Wolves und auf Ipswich. Und das ist, glaube ich, sehr, sehr ordentlich.
Und könnten jetzt Arsenal so richtig schlechte Laune dann besorgen, rund um Weihnachten, rum die Vorweihnachten, ist es noch erst im Pokal und dann in der Liga? Einmal ausfahrt, einmal zu Hause.
Wäre der absolute Klassiker. Verarsene. Oder ist es fast schon wieder zu billig ist.
Ich hab's gesehen, dachte mir so, oh oh. Na gut, wir schauen uns an, was da passiert. Aber schön zu hören, dass es bei Crystal Palace wieder ein bisschen positiverer Schlagzeilen zu berichten gibt, das freut alle Fans von Oliver Glasner. Dann machen wir nochmal eine schnelle Runde. Nils, was hast du uns noch mitgebracht?
Ja, früher war das ja die Kategorie Unsung Hero. Und jetzt kommt natürlich einer, der durchaus im Matridismo besungen wird. Na na na na na na na. Hey Jude, der aber in der Öffentlichkeit noch ein bisschen so hinterfragt wird, warum ist die die Tor-Serie von der letzten Hinrunde nicht mehr da? Ist er irgendwie im Formloch? Nö, Jude Bellingham hat einfach primär letzte Rückrunde, linkes Mittelfeld gespielt, nicht mehr so nah an der Box, auch weil Ancelotti mehr Offensivoptionen hatte. Und das war auch ein bisschen zu Beginn dieser Saison der Fall, als dann eben neben Wini und Rodrigo dann auch noch diese eine Franzose aus dem Rasenfunk-Intro eingesetzt wurde. Aber auch das ist jetzt die letzten Wochen, hat sich das ein bisschen geändert. Jude Bellinghams Knoten ist endlich geplatzt. Das war gegen OstraZuna, da war ich selbst noch dabei. Da hat er getroffen, jetzt so aus den letzten sieben Spielen, sechs Tore und drei Vorlagen. Und dann hätte er auch noch ein Elfmeter Liverpool schießen können, auch ein Elfmeter in Bilbao schießen können, aber hat da den bestimmten Franzosen den Vorzug gelassen. Also was ich sagen will, Jude Bellingham ist eigentlich schon auch das ganze Kalenderjahr gut, weil er sehr viel arbeitet, sehr viel ausstrahlt von der Körpersprache. Auch mal ein bisschen Gegenspieler anschnauzt oder ein bisschen hinterfragt, warum jetzt da der Laufweg oder das Gegenpressing nicht gekommen ist. Also er ist da schon auch extrem ehrgeizig, so kennt man ihn aus der Bundesliga, aber das wird schon durchaus positiv, in positive Energie umgewandelt im Madridismo oder generell auch in der Presse, dass es da nicht zu Polemikas kommt, wie Bellingham schnauzt Guller an, sondern Bellingham spornt Guller an, noch mehr zu machen und er hat dann auch das Tor gemacht und klar, von dem her ist da Bellingham gerade so ein bisschen unbesogen, weil ich glaube immer noch in der Öffentlichkeit viele denken, ja der ist das, der hat das war noch eine Ausnahme seine Hinrunde und jetzt danach ist er nichts mehr bei der Madrid. Nee, der ist ziemlich viel und jetzt kommen aktuell auch wieder die Torbeteiligung zurück.
Der wirkt ja auf mich wahnsinnig überspielt, sowohl schon in Teilen der Rückrunde, bei der EM hast du es dann in den guten Phasen nicht gesehen, aber in den schlechteren Phasen und es hing ja wahnsinnig viel an Bellingham bei England, bei dieser EM und dann kam er ja verletzt daraus, also eigentlich scheint es für mich eine total logische Entwicklung zu sein, der braucht ein bisschen Anlaufzeit und jetzt kommt er wieder langsam an sein altes Niveau heran, aber es gab trotzdem, das habe ich richtig verstanden, schon kritische Stimmen ihm gegenüber.
Nee, also bei Fans eher, die sich dann wundern, warum er keine Tore macht und man hat ihn doch geholt, um Tore zu machen, nee eben nicht, er ist halt ein sehr kompletter Mittelfeldspieler, der auch sehr viel arbeitet und kämpft und immer das Trikot irgendwie schmutzig hat und was so angesprochen hat, es so überspielt, Verletzung ist auch eine Wahrheit, bei ihm ist auch wieder so ein bisschen so eine alte Schulterverletzung aufgebrochen, man sieht bei ihm unter dem Trikot immer so eine schwarze Schutzweste, also das schleppt er noch ein bisschen mit sich rum und trotzdem auch ein zu 90 Prozent fitter Bellingham ist aktuell so der beste Matrilene oder in dieser Saison Top 3, weil er wie gesagt auch als einer von wenigen sehr viel Biss zeigt auf dem Platz und nicht immer nur alles so geschehen lässt und einfach auch sehr viel im Pressing wichtig ist, was bei Real ziemlich random ist und wir aber er zumindest gibt er immer noch Druck und er hat mittlerweile auch das Glück vom Tor wieder neun Torbeteiligung aus jetzt sieben Spielen ist schon ist da kein Zufall.
Aber wirklich.
Soll nicht ganz unwichtig sein auch für große Spieler, dass sie eine gute geordnete Vorbereitung haben, um langsam in Form zu kommen.
Amen.
Aber wir sind ja immer alle so ungeduldig, wir Beobachtenden. Daniel, was hast du noch in der Eredivisie für uns?
Ich hab was von Arsett Alkmaar mitgebracht und zwar Sven Meinanz. Das ist ja quasi auch so ein Ansagen hier. Bei Arsett ist es wieder eigentlich unfassbar, was da für Nachwuchsarbeit geleistet wird. Der Fokus liegt so ein bisschen auf Rüben van Bommel, das ist auch der Sohn von Marc van Bommel oder Kay Smeet zum Beispiel, der echt auch herausragend in den letzten Spielen abstrahliert hat auch international, trotz der roten Karte gegen Istanbul. Und er geht zumindestens seinen Meinanz unter. Der ist Zehner von Haus aus, hat aber mittlerweile, könnte man sagen, Polyvalent, als Sport, weil er auch mittlerweile zugezogen reagiert als Achter. Die letzten beiden Spiele war er Sechser, aber hat das gut gemacht und hat so ein bisschen so typische Box-to-Box-Qualitäten an den Tag gelegt, was sich halt auch an seinen relativ geringen Scoring-Punkten zeigt. Er hat jetzt drei Tore. Das ist in 15 Spielen für einen Zehner jetzt nicht unbedingt viel, aber es ist eben dann auch so wie bei Jude, weil er eben nicht nur an diesen Toren gemessen werden sollte, sondern eben auch an der Leistung fürs Team. Und der SS24 ist aber für das Alter auch schon relativ reif. Er ist auch fiese Kapitän gewesen, als der etatmäßige Jordi Klaasie mal rausgefallen ist, die Bünde übernommen. Er hat sich im Interview schützend vor seine Mitspieler gestellt, unter anderem vor Kees Meade, der diese gelb-rote gesiebert hat in der EL gegen Istanbul. Hat er auch gesagt, ja, passieren und er übernimmt viel Verantwortung und hat eben sportlich auch andere Qualitäten als nur die reinen Scorer-Punkte, weil er eben auch so ein bisschen das Herzstück stellt von AZ, da viele kluge Pässe einleitet. Und im Eishockey hat man ja oft diese Vor-Vor-Vorlage, diese dritte Vorlage.
Im Fußball ist es der Toni Kroospass.
Genau, der Toni Kroospass. Und Sven Meydans macht sehr viele Toni Kroospässe, die dann eben nicht in der Statistik auftauchen, die aber natürlich auch für das Kriieren von Torschancen, für das Einleiten von gefährlichen Aktionen einfach elementar sind. Und da ist er auch ein sehr starker Spieler und ist mit, wie gesagt, seinen 24 Jahren noch jung, noch sehr entwicklungsfähig, aber eben schon auf einem sehr guten Level, weil er sich eben auch anpassen kann, flexibel ist. Ich glaube, rechts außen war er auch schon mal die Saison. Demek leider der Mittelfeld, einfach sehr viel Position. Und das geht so ein bisschen unter, weil der Fokus bei AZ gerne auf diesen noch jüngeren Talenten liegt, wie Van Bommel oder wie KS Smith. Oder eben auf Parrot, den Stürmer, den ich auch schon mal hier, glaube ich, angeblich hatte. Und deswegen würde ich mal so ein bisschen das Licht auf Sen Mainans riechen.
Schön, dazu viel AZ-Liebe aus Italien auch rübergeschickt. Ich sag nur rein, dass zum Cob Mainas.
Oh ja, guter Ex-Vorschlager.
Hätten wir eine eigene Ligatur mal verdient. Das ist total, was da rumläuft an Talenten, das ist nicht normal, diese Youth-Sieger-Mannschaft von 22, Max Merding, hört sich an wie ein WWE-Wrestler, aber es ist so ein Firmino-Regent-Quarkmann, so quasi die Jungtyp.
Quarkmann, ja.
Und ein Aufregerspieler, dann gibt's noch den, der ist der krasseste von allen, Masterras, der ist glaube ich erst 17 oder so was. Also richtig gut.
Und das Erstaunliche ist auch, dass die relativ nahtlos, wenn sie in die Profiteam kommen, zu den ersten Herren kommen, funktionieren. Und das ist echt, hatten ja auch nicht immer so klappraundige Zeit, aber so ein Case Meet, die hatte man jetzt auch nicht seit Längerem auf dem Schirm. Und dann kommt die aber hoch und funktioniert relativ geordnet, macht auch seine Spiele, spielt international und macht das für das Alter schon gut. Und das ist von so einem Phänomen, dass man bei AZ eigentlich bei sehr, sehr vielen Spielern aus der eigenen Jugend hat. Und das ist ja auch das Geschäftsmodell quasi jetzt endlich von AZ, diese Talente dann eben zu verkaufen für viel Geld. Und dieses Geld wird dann eben auch nicht nur auf Markt investiert, sondern eben auch in Infrastruktur, eben auch in die Nachricht Akademie. Und das zahlt sich aus und das ist für viele auch in der R&D Vita selbst ein Vorbildsverein.
Also da werden wir auf jeden Fall noch weitere Anzwang Heroes und MVP und so weiter oder wie auch immer wir es dann nennen werden diese Kategorie sehen. Arzett Aikma und Sven Meinanz. Merkt euch den Namen hier, habt ihr ihn vielleicht zum ersten Mal gehört. Christian, worüber möchtest du noch gerne sprechen?
Ich bringe euch noch eine Brüdergeschichte mit. Ich gebe ja bekannte Beispiele aus Italien, die Insagi-Brüder vielleicht an die sich ein paar noch erinnern. Die Baresi-Brüder wissen vielleicht nicht alle, dass Franco Baresi auch einen Bruder hatte, der auch noch bei Inter gespielt hat. Ist egal, ist die Vergangenheit. Wir gehen jetzt eine Stufe höher, denn ich komm jetzt mit den Espositos-Brüder vorbei und die sind nicht nur zwei, sondern die sind so dritt. Und die hatten am vergangenen Sonntag einen ziemlich witzigen Sonntag, denn die drei haben, ich würde sagen ihr Papa hatte den schönsten Nachmittag, denn die drei haben innerhalb von 45 Minuten fünf Tore erzielt. Und zwar fangen wir an, Sebastiano Esposito hat in der Serie A zwei Puden gemacht für Empoli auswärts bei Hellas. Riesentalent, an dem hat Inter immer noch die Transferrechte zuletzt immer ein bisschen verliehen worden, um Spielpraxis zu sammeln. Aber da ist Inter wie gesagt auf den Zehntes über möglich auch noch für die Zukunft. Und dann gehen wir in der Liga drunter und zwar bei Spezia, die auch Top 3 in der Liga sind, Aufstiegsmitfavorit. Das spielen die anderen zwei Brüder, nämlich Salvatore und Pio. Ja und die haben halt auch drei Puden insgesamt gemacht beim 5-0-Sieg. Also und die Torabfolge war wirklich so, dass innerhalb von 45 Minuten hat der Papa von den Espositors oder die ganze Familie halt fünf Tore bejubeln können. Und zu den zwei Spezia-Spieler muss man auch noch sagen, Salvatore, das ist der älteste von denen, ein U21-Nationalspieler, das ist ein Sechser, ganz solider Spieler. Ich glaube, der wird auch demnächst noch Serie A, glaube ich. Eine gewisse Rolle spielen jetzt vielleicht nicht ganz oben, aber solide. Und Pio, das ist der jüngste, der ist 18, ist ein Mittelstürmer, ziemlich kantig, bisschen anders als Sebastiano, der technisch sehr guter ist. Pio bringt viel Füße mit und der ist wirklich nur von Inter ausgeliehen, ist 18 und hat in der Saison schon in der Serie B acht Buden gemacht. Also das ist einer vielleicht auch die nächsten Jahre bei Inter, vielleicht Stürmer Nummer drei, Nummer vier. Also ja, behaltet euch der Esposito aus dem Kopf, wie gesagt, fünf Tore in 45 Minuten, würde ich auch sagen, nicht unbedingt alltäglich.
Aber wirklich die Esposito Brüder, man weiß nicht, ob es eine Folge von Narcos ist oder eben ein Thema in der Liga Tour. Jetzt sind wir uns ganz sicher. Uli, worüber möchtest du noch sprechen?
Ich würde wahrscheinlich noch gerne über Brentford sprechen wollen. Die haben ein ganz normales für sie Ergebnis geholt. Das ist sozusagen so was wie Tottenham, nur dass es immer gut ausgeht. 4-2 gegen Newcastle, also zumindest gemessen an den Erwartungen. Die sind einfach neunter in der Saison, haben 31 erzielte Tore und 28 kassierte. Also es passiert einfach immer was, wenn die spielen. Das war schon mal so ähnlich so, nur dass es meistens in die schlechte Richtung ging. Ich hatte die potenziell als einen möglichen Absteiger, wenn die Dinge sich schlecht entwickeln würden. Die haben ja Ivan Thony verloren, was im Nachhinein ein Segen ist. Das habe ich mir schon fast gedacht, aber ich hab nicht. Also die spielen eigentlich seit Jahren mit dem gleichen Kern, der auch aufgestiegen ist. Die sind alle zusammen älter geworden, ist aber auch eine schöne Geschichte. Es funktioniert aber. Und warum ich das mache ist, ist es ein Video, eineinhalb Minuten, zwei nur lang, rausgekommen, kann ich dir vielleicht schicken, dann Max, kannst du es vielleicht verlinken, wo man sieht wie Thomas Frank die Jungs dann direkt anspricht, wenn er in die Kabine kommt.
Habe ich sogar schon gesehen.
Zeigt diese unglaublich guten kommunikativen Fähigkeiten. Es ist nothing special was er da macht. Das ist eine ganz normale Ansprache an ein Team, aber ich habe mir das drei, viermal angeschaut, einfach auch nur auf verschiedene Dinge zu achten. A wie spricht er, nennt jeden Einzelnen, der gespielt hat, ganz kurz, aber auch die, die nicht spielen vor allen Dingen. Und man sieht, wenn er dann die einzelnen Spieler nennt, das Lächeln in den Gesichtern, aber vor allen Dingen rundherum auch die, wie sie darauf reagieren. Und da merkt man irgendwie, dass so Zusammenhalt da. Und ich würde vieles davon, und das weiß ich auch aus dem Verein heraus, auf die kommunikativen Fähigkeiten des Cheftrainers schicken, der glaube ich überdurchschnittlich begabt ist in dem Punkt. Und auch mit ganz einfachen Worten vieles richtig sagt. Und das ist wahrscheinlich ein singulärer Grund dafür, dass Brentford da oben steht. Deswegen wollte ich die einfach mal genannt haben.
So schön Uli, dass du sowas ansprichst, weil da vielleicht, hatte ich vorhin vergessen, dann kann man Baroni noch mal kurz reinnehmen. Es ist so schön, dass eben auch eine gute Kommunikation aus Trainersicht, wie du sagst, das muss ja kein Zauberwerk sein, aber es ist einfach kommunikativ gut, wie wichtig das ist. Ein Satz noch zu Baroni. Baroni wie gesagt, der sagt, das ist die Chance meines Lebens mit 61. Der hat vor kurzem auch mal erzählt, er schaut sich jede seiner eigenen Pressekonferenzen noch mal an und lässt die Revue passieren, weil er sagt, Kommunikation sowohl Richtung Außen als auch Journalisten, als auch Teamentdehren, als auch seine Ansprachen schaut er sich noch mal an, ist halt einfach unfassbar wichtig. Und da ist es so schön, wenn ich das höre, weil es halt auch Trainer gibt, die auch den Bereich, die wissen, dass das ein wahnsinnig wichtiger Punkt ist. Und noch mal, da reden wir jetzt nicht von Zauberei, oder du musst da nicht jede Woche die Ansprache des Lebens halten, sondern du musst einfach das Ganze gut empathisch machen. Und Baroni passt halt auch genau in die Riege rein, weil er sich einfach Gedanken dazu macht und das Ganze halt als wichtiges Thema aus der Korn hat. Deswegen, sorry dazu, das passt da wunderbar rein. Sehr schön, dass man so was hört.
Und in diesem Video, da siehst du vor allem die Wertschätzung für die Spieler, auch für die Spieler, die nicht gespielt haben, also dass er darauf eingeht. Und ganz ehrlich, ein Typ, der in der Premier League-Kabine steht und in einem leichten Akzent seine Spieler lobt und sich das anfühlt wie eine Familie. Ich hatte so harte Ted Lasso-Vibes. Das ist...
Du hattest gehofft, du sagst nicht Jürgen Klopp oder so.
Nein, komplett anders. Der hat ja vorher nicht irgendwie dem Schiedsrichterassistenten den Kopf abgebissen.
Das stimmt sogar, ja das stimmt sogar.
Also und ich hab noch ein anderes Video neulich von Thomas Frank gesehen, da hat er einfach darüber gesprochen, warum Distanzschüsse keinen Sinn ergeben, eben Expected Goals Werte, wie man sie vorbereiten kann und so weiter und so fort. Auch ganz ruhig, das war jetzt nichts besonderes, das war jetzt auch inhaltlich nicht so, dass man sich gedacht hat, oh das hab ich ja noch nie gehört im Fußball, aber einfach die Art und Weise, wie er das auf Augenhöhe mit dem Experten im Studio besprochen hat und aber auch selber jetzt nicht so getan hat, als ob er hier gerade Herrschaftswissen verteilt.
Ich hab das hier eh mal erzählt, wir waren kurz vor der Pandemie in England, haben damals Gott sei Dank noch das alte Stadion gesehen und haben da Thomas Frank auch sprechen können, weil er aber auf uns zukam. Also mein Bruder und mich, meine ich damit. Wir haben einfach sozusagen zwei Zweitligaspiele geguckt damals, unter der Woche sind dahin und ich hab ihm irgendeine Frage gestellt, da waren die schon so im Fringe-Aufstiegsrennen mit dabei und hab ihm eine Frage gestellt und haben wir uns dann um den Begriff Athletik und Dynamik gestritten und er wollte meine Definition von Athletik haben, dann hab ich ihm die gegeben und gesagt, ich würde nicht sagen, dass wir das athletischste Team der Liga sind, aber das dynamischste. Und dann hat er auf dieser Frage fünf Minuten rumgeritten, hat ihm total Spaß gemacht und dann kommt er, also damals in dem alten Stadion bei Brentford, das ist jetzt kein Pressekonferenzraum, sondern das war halt so das Sportheim von hinten. Dann ist er halt so reingebeten worden. Marcelo Bielsa im Übrigen war sein Gegner damals gegen Leeds und Marcelo Bielsa kam halt mit seinem mit seiner Entourage da rein, mit Übersetzer und so weiter. Und hat halt niemanden angeschaut in dem ganzen Raum. Wir saßen alle so da, also vor der Pandemie, muss man noch mal wissen, war im Nachhinein ein besonders behagliches Gefühl. Und da saßen wir alle so da und Marcelo Bielsa hat halt seine drei Fragen, die er halt machen musste und ist dann abgezogen. Ich habe es echt versucht, aber keine Chance. Und bei Thomas Frank war es so, der hat sich halt Zeit genommen, hat jeden einzelnen so mehr oder weniger begrüßt. Der kannte halt die ganzen anderen Typen da so und kannte halt auch so ungefähr die Fragen, die kamen und dann kamen halt meine. Und dann sind wir draußen gestanden, die Mixed Zone war hinter so einem Bauzaun und wir haben halt noch ein paar Leute gewartet. Und irgendwann kommt der auf uns zu und sagt, Jungs, wer seid denn ihr eigentlich? Und das ist halt einfach der Chef-Trainer. Und dann hab ich gesagt, ja wieso denn? Ja, weil so eine Frage hat er noch nie gehört. Die meisten wollen halt nur wissen Verletzungen und so Zeugs. Und dann hat er uns die Hand geschüttelt und gesagt, ja Deutschland, er spricht auch ein bisschen Deutsch, hat dann so zwei, drei Brocken halt raus und dann haben wir so fünf Minuten noch geredet und so weitergegangen. Hast du schon gemerkt, der ist irgendwie anders. Es ist special. In dem Punkt wenigstens.
Und da kann man auch Schulter am Schulter im Pressekonferenzraum sitzen und sich das sehr gerne anhören. Jetzt machen wir noch eine ganz schnelle Runde, dass wenn ich zu sehr über euer Zeitbudget drüber gehen Nies. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, du hast 30 Sekunden. Nee, Quatsch. Was ist denn das letzte Thema?
Schaff ich. Es ist eigentlich eine schöne Entwicklung, dass jetzt mehr und mehr Langzeitpatienten in La Liga zurückkehren. Wir hatten ja schon in den letzten Wochen einen Gavi bei Barca, der zurückgesetzt ist. Ronald Araucho stand wieder im Kader. David Alaba teilweise schon im Mannschaftstraining, auch wenn der wohl erst im Januar wieder eingesetzt wird. Und da gab es jetzt auch am Wochenende ein schönes Comeback bei Betis. Das war Isco, der hat wegen Wadenbeinbruch lange gefehlt. Und ja, La Liga ist natürlich auch von schweren Verletzungen nicht gefällt. Auch Dani Cavajal, Eder Militao und auch viele andere Kreuzbandrisse gibt es da. Aber es ist auch dann immer wieder mal zu schön zu sehen, dass es dann eben auch zu den erhofften Comebacks kommt. Und da habe ich jetzt natürlich auch viele vergessen, die da auch verletzt sind. Aber das ist eine nette Entwicklung und ich bin gespannt, wer jetzt als nächstes eine nette Geschichte noch raushauen kann. Wie hatten wir die Reihenfolge? Jetzt kam als nächstes Daniel, oder?
Genau. Ich mache noch ganz schnell zwei kleine Themen. Das eine ist der Europa Blues von Playzways zurück, der Europamythos. In der Liga dominieren sie eigentlich alles, haben mit 6 zu 1 gegen Trente gewonnen. Und gegen Press ist es mir unerklärlich, wie das verloren gegangen sein konnte. Die erste Halbzeit hatten sie unglaublich viele Chancen. In der zweiten Halbzeit war es da nicht mehr ganz so gut. Und das ist oft so ein Thema in der Rallye Divisi, dass die vor allem PSV Eindhoven in der Liga alles dominiert und dann gegen vermeintlich auf dem Papier etwa gleichwertige Gegner, wo man sagen muss, dass Press natürlich eine herausragende Saison spielt in der Champions League, dass das da eben nicht läuft. Und oft kriegen sie ihren Boschball nicht auf den Rasen. Jetzt am Dienstag eigentlich schon. Und trotzdem hatten sie einfach unglaublichen Chancenwucher, was sehr untypisch ist für PSV. Und das eigentliche Highlight oder Lowlight, wie man möchte, kam dann nämlich im Anschluss, nämlich auch Stichwort Kommunikation des Trainers, der öffentlich dann sehr ungehalten war und gesagt hat, das war der schlechteste Spiel, seitdem er dort Trainer ist. Seit der ersten Sekunde hätte ihm nichts gefallen an diesem Spiel, wo ich sage, so schlimm war es eigentlich gar nicht. Aber Peter Bosz war sehr ungehalten und das ist einfach so ein Mysterium in der Eredivisie, diese Unfähigkeit von Belswey, sage ich mal, dieses Unglück in der ECL einfach so aufzutreten, eben nicht wie in der Liga. Und das zweite kurze Ding, als schöner Rauschmeister der Eredivisie hatten wir ja zu Beginn das traurige Thema mit dem Sponsor-Namen ab der kommenden Saison der Liga. Aber es gibt auch eine gute Unterricht für alle Traditionistinnen, nämlich das alte Ajax-Logo kehrt zurück ab nächster Saison. Verabschiedet man sich von diesem sehr abstrakten Logo der letzten Jahre und geht zurück zu dem alten Logo, was bis zu den 90er Jahren auf der Post hängt, war auch ein großer Wunsch der Fans. Und es ist im Prinzip auch zum 125. Jubiläum von Ajax, was sie nächstes Jahr feiern. Der Anlass. Und das wird aber dauerhaft dann wieder auf die Tikus zu sehen sein. Das ist so ein schöner Abfluss für mich.
Aber wirklich, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich, dass ihr das mal kurz hier in Eigenregie weiter gemacht habt. Ich hatte ja nach der Sendung, was hier gerade rauskam. Christian, welches Thema hast du noch dabei?
Ja, ich bringe noch eins. Wir sind ja nicht mehr so weit von Weihnachten entfernt. Dann bringe ich vielleicht eine kleine Geschichte, die ein bisschen herzerwärmt ist mit Fußball in Rom. Das ist eine Geschichte, die war ziemlich medial begleitet. 2019 war da ein Unfall, wo ein älterer Herr ins Koma gefallen ist, quasi als Autounfall. Und der hat dann, also den konnte sie aus dem Koma wieder hervorholen, aber der hat einfach 39 Jahre seines Lebens sozusagen, waren nicht mehr präsent. Also er ist 2019 ins Koma gefallen und das Letzte, was er sich erinnern konnte, war irgendwie im März Tag 1980. Und warum konnte er sich an den erinnern? Weil er ein großer Roma-Fan war. Und die Roma war damals in der Saison halt gut, ja, noch im Rennen. Und das war somit sein letzter Moment, den er sich erinnern konnte quasi. Und er hat dann, also es ist wirklich eine ganz berührende Geschichte, weil da kam dann zum Beispiel, als er aus dem Koma erwacht ist, kam seine Frau ans Bett und er hat gemeint, hä, wie, das kann nicht meine Frau sein, ich bin ja mit einer 19-Jährigen verlobt und wir sollten eigentlich ein paar Monaten heiraten. Und das war aber seine Frau. Er hat auch seinen Sohn nicht erkannt, weil sein Sohn erst später geboren ist. Und so, lange Rede kurze Sinde zur Einleitung. Und die Roma hat das jetzt zum Anlass genommen, weil er halt eben diesen tiefen Bezug hatte, ihn einzuladen, hat mit Ruggero Rozzitelli, den ihr vielleicht auch noch ein paar aus Deutschland kennen, genau, ehemaliger Feiernstürmer, der hat sich die Zeit genommen und hat ihn ja durch Trigoria geführt, durchs Roma-Zentrum. Und da wurden halt immer wieder quasi so kleine Fragmente, an die konnte er sich erinnern, ah ja, das war ja die Bartolomeo, damals der Roma-Kapitän, wenn er Bilder gesehen hat. Und zum Beispiel, er hat dann Bilder gesehen von Francesco Totti und er kannte Francesco Totti nicht, weil er eben wie gesagt von 1980 bis 2019 sozusagen, ja, seine ganze Erinnerung weg sind. Also wirklich berührend. Die Roma hat das halt auf Social Media auch begleitet. Und der ältere Herr, jetzt fällt mir der Name nicht ein, hat halt echt gesagt, was schön ist, er hat gesagt, er kann sich wirklich immer noch das meiste nicht erinnern, aber sie haben viel mehr Psychologen jetzt in den letzten Jahren gearbeitet. Und so gewisse Fragmente sind, kommen wieder, Kleinigkeiten und einige davon sind halt mit der Roma verbunden. Deswegen vielleicht eine schöne kleine Weihnachtsgeschichte, dass der Fußball halt eben manchmal auch in so, ja bei so schweren Schicksalen, dann halt auch einen kleinen Grund liefern kann, um was zum Positiveren zu bewegen.
Es ist nicht komplett das gleiche Thema, aber artverwandt. Und ich möchte die Botschaft kurz raussenden. Wenn wir über solche Erinnerungslücken und eben zum Beispiel auch Demenz sprechen, dann ist der Fußball nachgewiesenermaßen tatsächlich etwas, was oft Menschen helfen kann, die an Demenz erkrankt sind, sich wieder an Dinge zu erinnern, was ja auch ein Stück Teilhabe am Leben bedeutet. Deswegen, es gab dazu schon Studien, irgendwann vor ein paar Jahren habe ich das im Rasenfunk auch schon mal kurz angesprochen, mit, dass eben genau das ist, dass eben gerade Fußballfans, die an Demenz erkranken, dadurch eben ein bisschen Teilhabe erfahren und sich eben wieder an Dinge erinnern, die vorher im Nebel verschwunden waren. Und es gibt verschiedene Vereine. Ich habe es jetzt hier über eine schnelle Recherche, gerade beim FC Bayern zum Beispiel gefunden, die sogenannte Erinnerungskoffer anbieten. Das heißt, wenn ihr eben in eurem Umfeld Demenzerkrankte oder an anderen ähnlichen Erkrankungen leidende Menschen in eurem Umfeld habt, dann informiert euch da mal was, ob es da vielleicht was gibt. Wenn das eben Fußballfans sind, dann kann man eben diese Erinnerungskoffer dann sich ausleihen auf eine Art und Weise und eben damit ein paar schöne Stunden vielleicht verbringen wieder mit den Betroffenen. Deswegen wollte ich das hier kurz ansprechen. Ich verlinke jetzt mal das, was ich dazu gefunden habe, aber dass der Fußball da eine große Rolle spielen kann, ist absolut schon nachgewiesen und das sollte man vielleicht auf dem Schirm haben, wenn es einen Leiter dann vielleicht im Umfeld betrifft. Also sehr schöner Hinweis. Vielen Dank, Christian. So, dann gehen wir noch ein letztes Mal nach England. Uli, was hast du für uns?
Nichts Neues, aber er muss einfach genannt werden. Hinten raus in dem Jahr Cole Palmer ist eine Sensation. Deswegen bitte kudos to him. Hat die meisten Torbeteiligungen für Chelsea in einem Kalenderjahr. Jimmy Floyd Hasselbank abgelenkt. Auch deswegen, da bin ich ganz ehrlich, dass der Name auch mal hier fällt. Das ist einfach Wahnsinn. Cole Palmer ist wahrscheinlich das nächste am sportlichen Christiano Ronaldo, was wir je gesehen haben, weil der einfach manchmal den Ball packt und Dinge ermöglicht, von denen du denkst, es geht nicht. Und der Reiß des Spiels so an sich hat, dieser Name Cole Palmer, oder inzwischen finde ich viel besser als Karma, oder Calma, auch Spanisch, das ist wirklich so. Der steht halt einfach da, kann das Spiel drehen gegen Tottenham und macht halt logischen Panenka. Ist klar. Und dann auch danach, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass er sich einen grinst oder so, sondern geht halt einfach stoisch weiter und macht halt weiter sein Ding. Ist wirklich ein fantastischer Fußballer. Deswegen, und auch Chelsea jetzt im Moment zweiter, gibt jetzt die Diskussion in England, ist Chelsea zurück oder nicht? Soweit würde ich jetzt noch nicht gehen wollen. Wahrscheinlich wird Chelsea nie wieder zurückkommen in der Art und Weise, wie wir sie kannten, sondern eben auf ihre Art und Weise. Aber für Platz zwei hat Cole Palmer große Verantwortung.
Uli, in die Richtung demnächst bitte auch mal ein bisschen mehr zu Chelsea, auch zu Enzo Maresca, hab jetzt auch vieles aus Italien mitbekommen dazu. Also ich glaube auch spannend, weil ich glaube, der hat da auch einiges in die gute Bahn gelenkt, was bei Chelsea in den letzten Jahren nicht selbstverständlich war.
Unglaublich. Also Maresca hab ich als einer der Top-5-Trainer der Liga im Moment. Das sieht von Spiel zu Spiel besser aus und wie du sagst, auch da ein kommunikativer Aspekt. Der macht es zwar eher auf eisige Art und Weise, aber das ist wahrscheinlich genau das, was die gebraucht haben bei Chelsea, dass der einfach mal sagt, komm, Schluss jetzt mit der Show hier. Ich hol mir jetzt mal die 24 Leute, die ich brauche und der Rest von denen will ich auch nie wieder irgendwas sagen.
Von der 52.
Genau, der andere Bus, dem hat man im Navigationssystem was Falsches eingestellt.
Hilf dem noch so bei Brückwärts einparken und dann geht's los. Trainingsgruppe 2 und 3 sind hier, Leute. Also Schluss mit der Show. Schluss mit der Show ist jetzt tatsächlich auch an dieser Stelle. Und sofern nicht noch irgendwelche unvorhergesehenen Dinge passieren, wahrscheinlich auch mit der internationalen Ligatur. In diesem Sinne danke ich euch vieren, stellvertretend für alle Gäste, die wir in diesem Jahr hatten. Es hat ganz fantastisch viel Spaß gemacht nach dem Feedback, was ich bekommen habe, auch den Hörern und Hörern. Also ganz herzlichen Dank, stellvertretend für alle anderen an Uli Hebel, an Nies Kern, an Christian Bernhardt und Daniel Zander. Top Verstärkung, mega cool, dass wir jetzt immer mal wieder auch die Niederlande mit dabei haben. Und wenn ich sehe, wie da auch die anderen aufblühen, wenn über Alkmaar gesprochen wird, da denke ich mir schon, meine Güte, was haben wir liegen lassen in den vergangenen Jahren? Aber jetzt ist es ja da. Also danke euch vieren. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei wart.
Gerne, danke. Danke. Danke ja auch. Schöne Weihnachtszeit noch.
Die wünsche ich allen anderen auch bei schöner Wärme in der eigenen Bleibe. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Und ihr wisst ja, alles hier ist Werbe, Paywall und Sponsoren frei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Till, Seppl, Seba bei Hossa77, bei Florian, bei Tuoboris und bei Thomas Marks. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Jeder Betrag hilft und es geht auch etwas an unsere Gäste. Vielen herzlichen Dank, dass ihr die Ligatur in diesem Jahr so fleißig gehört habt. Empfehlt uns sehr gerne weiter. Bleibt uns gewogen und vor allem bleibt gesund. Bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.
Ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.